AFTERNOON WELCOME TO THE JOINT
OVERSIGHT HEARING.
WAS ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM AND
INTERNET MEDIA.
END THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FOR YOUR INTEREST FULL OF AND
AND BEING HERE.
I CAN SEE THAT -- WOULD WOULD.
IF WE KNOW AHEAD OF THE TIME WE
WILL PROBABLY BE SCHEDULE A A
BIGGER OF A COMMITTEE ROOM.
BUT TO THAT THE FACT IS THERE
ARE SO MANY COMEY HE'S ARE GOING
ON RIGHT NOW.
IN -- PULLS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AND MYSELF MIGHT HAVE
TO
EXCUSE YOURSELF A LITTLE BIT.
MAKE SURE THAT WE GOT OF A
QUORUM AND THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
AND AND ALSO VOTED ON THE TAX
AND REVENUE COMING HERE ACROSS
THE HALL AND SOULS WHO WILL WILL
PROBABLY.
IN AND OUT IN NO YOU FIRST -- N.
DIAL I KNOW THERE ARE FEW OTHER
MEMBERS PROBABLY WILL YOU KNOW
CAN POP IN AND OUT -- THOSE
THROUGH ALL OF THIS -- HEARING.
AND THIS HEARING WILL FOCUS ON
THE INTERSECTION.
INTERSECT THE SECTION TO OVERLAP
AND THE GAP IF ANY.
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL TITLE NIGHT
AND THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
COLD.
ON SEX ACT EQUALITY IN EDUCATION
LOS INFO FEELING INFO FILLING
DEAR SHARE THE GOAL.
OF ACHIEVING EQUAL ****.
IN ALL ASPECTS OF EDUCATION.
REGARDLESS OF GENDER.
ARE WE HAVING A BY THAT THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE.
AS WELL AS ACADEMIA AND LEGAL
EXPERT.
IN GENDER EQUITY IN EDUCATION
AND SPORTS.
BUT BEFORE WE STARTED THIS YEAR
HEARING WE DO HAVE SOME FORMAL
PRESENTATION.
THE I LIKE -- TO TAKE A LOOK
MORE MOMENT TO HONOR TO
OUTSTANDING LEADERS IN THE FIELD
OF WOMEN'S SPORTS.
ALL OF HE EQUITY OWNED SO WALT --
FIRST ONE WOULD GO -- TO HAD THE
GOAL THERE AND KATIE
[inaudible]
HARDIMAN HARDIMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PLEASE COME FOR A AND A SOB
DOES RESOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
GERRY THE NATALIE.
LITTLE LITTLE BACKGROUND ABOUT
DOES DID TO TO A JERRY IS THAT --
A JURY WAS A LONG TIME LOBBYIST
AND CIVIL RIGHTS ADVOCATE.
BUT IN ADDITION JURY -- WAS A
PIONEER SOME WOMAN SOCCER WHO
WORK FORTY SEVEN YEARS IN
WOMEN'S SOCCER AS A COACH.
OWNER AND LEAGUE COMMISSIONER HE
FOUNDED THE WOMAN'S PREMIERES
SOCCER LEAGUE IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AND WITHIN
TWENTY YEARS THE LEAGUE GROWN
INTO THE LARGEST WOMEN'S SOCCER
LEAGUE IN THE WORLD.
A JURY FUNDED AND COLDS THE
CALIFORNIA STORM.
AND EXXON COMENTO CLUB BECAMEA
DOMINATE FORCE WAS SEEN THE
LEAGUE ONE THREE LEAGUE
CHAMPIONSHIP AND THREE
ADDITIONAL RUN IN UP FINISHES.
THE LIST OF A PLAY YOUR A JURY
COACHED.
AND THE STORM IS EXTRAORDINARY
NOTABLE.
FIFA WOMEN WORLD CUP STARRED
BRANDY -- TRUST AND I BELIEVE
BRENDA LOOKED IN MY MY DISTRICT
SOMEWHERE IN SAN JOSE.
AND TO LEAVE FONG.
THREE ALEX MORGAN AND THE
CAPITALS OWN KATIE HARMAN.
SO -- SADLY JERRY POSSIBLY --
LAST YEAR.
THE BUT HIS LEGACY WILL LIVE
FALL WAS THAT I WOULD -- MY
COLLIE.
MEDINA AND I OWE MORE WORK COME.
THE OUR TOP CALI TO MAYBE TAKE A
GROUP PICTURE WE WE WOULD DO IT.
I DON'T KNOW HERE.
RIGHT HERE WAS A BLACK OKAY.
JUST A LITTLE BIT [inaudible]
AT WE WILL GO AHEAD.
WHERE [inaudible]
THIS WILL.
THAT WOULD BE [inaudible]
ONE RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY.
REALLY QUICK -- ACTUALLY STARTED
A WOMEN'S SOCCER TEAM FOR PEOPLE
WORKING.
CAPITAL ABOUT THIRTY YEARS AGO
AND ALL OF US INCLUDING SENATE
SERGEANT WOMEN AND ASSEMBLY
SERGEANT WOMEN AND SOME OF THE
STAFF PEOPLE WHO WERE WORKING IN
THE CAPITAL WE ALSO A AND WE
WERE.
IN OUR FORTIES THAT WE AND YEAH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALSO -- WILL COME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COME A LOGGER DOLPH BUT
JOINING US THANK YOU.
EARNED AND THE NEXT ONE WE HAVE
THE WE HAVE ANOTHER.
A RESOLUTION. 2% OR ELIZABETH
CHRIS QUESTION.
AND KIM TURNER.
WELL THEY'RE BOTH FROM HOW OF
HERE.
THERE WAS DUBBED THE RESOLUTION
THERE WOULD BE RECEIVING A
SECOND RESOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
OF FAIR PLAY FOR GIRLS IN SPORTS.
THE FAIR PLAY FOR GIRLS IN
SPORTS PROJECT LAUNCHING INTO.
TWENTY ELEVEN REPRESENTING GIRLS
PARTICULARLY IN MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL.
SEEKING TO ENSURE THAT FEMALE
USE ING UNDERSERVED AREA LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY AND COMMUNITY
OF CALLERS CAN JOINS.
FOURTEEN IN EXPERIMENTS TO EQUAL
ALL THE EQUALITY ON SUCH TEAMS.
THE FIRST FAIR PLAY CASE WAS --
IN.
TWO THOUSAND THREE WAS THE A
SUCCESSFUL TRUCE VERSUS THE EL
HAMBRE.
CLASS ACTION.
AT ADDRESSING GENDER INEQUALITY
IN ATHLETIC.
THE LOS ANGELES AREA HIGH SCHOOL.
OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS THE
FAIR PLAY PROJECT.
HAS SPUR SCHOOLS TO UPGRADE
ATHLETE FOR SO HE TO EQUALIZE
TREATMENT M. BENEFIT FOR FEMALE
ATHLETES.
IN NEW.
A TEAMS FOR GIRLS WERE
OPPORTUNITY LACK IN IMPROVE --
AMENITIES SUCH AS UNIFORM AND
LOCKER ROOMS THAT OFF FOR TOO
LONG WORK AND BE COOL.
THEY HAVE ALSO BEING
INSTRUMENTAL IN ADVANCING THE
CALLS ALL FOR YOU QUALITY HERE
IN THE CAPITAL.
BY TESTIFYING IN SO PLAIN
RESEARCHERS AND POLICY ADVISERS
IN FACT WERE HERE FUND -- JUST A
LITTLE BIT LATER SO PLEASE I
JOIN ME -- WELL COMING AND
RECOGNIZE -- WHO VOTED ELIZABETH
AND KIM [inaudible]
YOU.
THE HOTEL WITH -- YEAH
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
YEAH -- OKAY.
SO LONG.
THIS MINE.
FIRSTLY.
THE COFFEE MAKING THE FIRST YEAR.
ALL RIGHT RE RETURNING TO THE
FORMAL PORTION OF THE HEARING.
I I WANT TO THANK US FAMILY
MEMBERS MEDINA.
AND THE DATE THE CHAIR OFF
HIGHER ASK COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WHO HAVE JOINED US TODAY AND IN
THE IMPORTANT DISCUSSION OF
EDUCATION EQUALITY AN ASSET?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
YOU'LL HAVE A LONG I MAKE A
QUICK COMMENT.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AS PART
OF THIS JOINT HEARING -- TITLE
NINE WAS CREATED OVER FORTY
YEARS AGO AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN
POSITIVE CHANGES OVER THE LAST
FEW DECADES I KNOW THERE IS ROOM
FOR GROWTH.
AS A FATHER TO A DAUGHTER AND
NOW A GRAND FATHER TO A
GRANDDAUGHTER I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT.
TITLE NINE IS.
NOT CONCERNED WITH WHAT APPEARS
TO BE A ROLLING BACK IF YOU WILL
OF SEVERAL ELEMENTS OF TITLE.
NINE LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM THE WITNESSES AND ARE THE
MOST INTERESTED IN HEARING HOW
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS ARE
TACKLING THE RICK RECENT PROPOSE
FEDERAL CHANGES. TO TITLE NINE
SO -- MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING THIS HEARING TO HAVE
THANK YOU CHAIR MEDINA 	NG
COME A LEGAL DOLLS.
DO YOU HAVE AN ANSWER QUICK
ROMANO I JUST WANT -- TO THANK
YOU FOR CONVENING -- THIS JOINT
HEARING IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR ME TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
ISSUES AS IT RELATES TO TITLE
NINE AND GENDER EQUITY.
AND I YOU KNOW I THINK -- IT
SHOULDN'T BE LOST ON FOLKS THAT
THIS IS MARCH WERE IN THE MIDDLE
OF MARCH MADNESS AND WHILE IT'S
ALL ABOUT THE NC A A TOURNAMENT.
IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
THAT SPORTS PLAYS IN EDUCATION
AND ULTIMATELY IN MANY INSTANCES
HELPING SOME FOLKS.
GET ACROSS THE EDUCATIONAL
FINISH LINE -- YOU KNOW BECAUSE
IT'S STILL.
AN UNATTAINABLE ASPIRATION FOR
MANY COMMUNITIES -- AND SO HOW
WE CAN CONTINUE TO BRIDGE THE
GAP ESPECIALLY OUT YEAH.
IN RELATIONSHIP TO THE GENDER
ISSUES -- IS IMPORTANT SO THANK
YOU FOR CONVENING MATH THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
AND JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT OUR
PACKAGE AVAILABLE WAS HEARING
AGENDA BACKGROUND MATERIALS
THERE AND BIOS FULL ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS ARE TODAY -- BEFORE
PROCEEDING ARE LIKE -- TO TAKE A
FEW MINUTES SO ON ADDRESS AND
SOLVE TO HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS IN
IN THAT ENSURE THAT WE'RE HERE
FROM EVERYONE.
I FIRST FIRST ONE FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL ARE LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
TO RECOGNIZE THAT -- THIS IS A
PUBLIC HEARING AND WE'LL DISCUSS
SENSITIVE TOPICS IN I RESPECT IT
WE WANT TO CONDUCT THEMSELVES IN
THE MOST RESPECTFUL MANNER.
AND ALSO -- ASTRA TO YOUR
PANELISTS KEEP THEIR
PRESENTATION TO THE TIME
ALLOCATED WOULD HAVE A TIME
KEEPER HERE WE GO BUT THE HOTEL
VOLUNTEER TIME KEEPER HERE.
ALL RIGHT SO AND AND AND AND
EACH PANEL WILL BE FOLLOWED BY A
QUESTION WHO IN A A PORTION FOR
THE MEMBERS A MEMBERS ONLY.
ON THE DETAILS OF THE TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF TWO PRESENTERS THE
PUBLIC WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK UP.
TO IT WILL BE A TITLE NINE
OVERVIEW PRESENTATION BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
A HIGHER EDUCATION PANEL AND WE
WILL CLOSE WAS KATE TWELVE PANEL
FOLLOWED BY A PUBLIC COMMON.
IN IN THE END.
IT'S A AS I MENTIONED BEFORE THE
FOCUS OF TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE
ON THE CURRENT STATE.
OF TAX TITLE NINE BUT BEFORE WE
GETTING TO WHERE WE ARE NOW --
OUR FIRST SPEAKER ALECIA HUFFMAN
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMAN THE STATE TITLE
NIGHT.
COMMITTEE CHAIR -- WILL GIVE US
SOME BACKGROUND INFORMATION AND
AND IN CONTACT SO PLEASE --
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M SO USED TO BEING ABLE TO
TALK SORT OF A AT
GENDER
FAIRNESS FOR ALL POSITION IN ALL
OF THE WORK THAT WE UNDERTAKE.
DESPITE PROGRESS CHALLENGES TO
GENDER EQUITY IN EDUCATION STILL
EXISTS AND I AM PLEASED TO SHARE
A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF GENDER
EQUITY LAWS.
AND WHAT WORK STILL NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD.
WHEN I WAS A CLASSROOM TEACHER
MIGHT?
THEME WAS EDUCATION IS NOT A
SPECTATOR SPORT GET OFF OF THE
BENCH AND INTO THE GAME.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE THE U.
S. COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN ISSUED A REPORT
DOCUMENTING THE SECONDARY STATUS
OF WOMEN IN THE UNITED STATES
WITH A SPECIAL FOCUS.
ON WOMEN'S ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGES ONE OF THE RESULTS
OF THAT STUDY WAS THE EQUAL PAY
ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY THREE THE
CIVIL RIGHTS CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR WAS THE
NATION'S PREMIER CIVIL RIGHTS
LEGISLATION.
THE ACT OUTLAWED DISCRIMINATION
ON THE BASIS OF RACE COLOR
RELIGION SEX OR NATIONAL ORIGIN
REQUIRED EQUAL ACCESS TO PUBLIC
PLACES AND EMPLOYMENT.
AND ENFORCE DESEGREGATION OF
SCHOOLS.
THE PROTECTIONS BASED ON SEX
HOWEVER WERE NOT FULLY REALIZED
UNDER THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT
THEREFORE IN RESPONSE TO PUBLIC
PRESSURE FOR SEX EQUITY IN
SCHOOL.
TITLE NINE WAS SPONSORED BY A
YOU W. MEMBER REPRESENTATIVE
PATSY MINK OF HAWAII AND
SENATORS BIRCH BY AND GEORGE
MCGOVERN.
A A YOU W. BECAME AN IMPORTANT
VOICE IN THE COALITION WORK THAT
SUCCESSFULLY PROMOTED THE
PASSAGE OF TITLE.
NINE PRESIDENT NIXON SIGNED THE
EDUCATION AMENDMENTS OF SEVENTY
TWO IN JUNE AND IT BECAME
EFFECTIVE JULY.
ONE NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO TITLE
NINE SIMPLY STATES NO PERSON IN
THE UNITED STATES SHALL ON THE
BASIS OF SEX BE EXCLUDED FROM
PARTICIPATION IN.
BE NOT DENIED THE BENEFITS OF OR
BE SUBJECTED TO DISCRIMINATION
UNDER ANY EDUCATION PROGRAM OR
ACTIVITY RECEIVING FEDERAL
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE.
COURT ORDERED BUSING WAS MORE
VISIBLE MORE CONTROVERSIAL THAN
BANNING SEX DISCRIMINATION IN
SCHOOLS. TO A LARGE EXTENT TITLE
NINE DID NOT GARNER ATTENTION
FROM ANYONE UNTIL IT WAS ALREADY
LAW AND THEN OPPONENTS BEGAN
EFFORTS TO WEAKEN THE IMPACT OF
TITLE.
NINE THE LARGEST LOBBYING
CAMPAIGN AGAINST TITLE NINE CAME
FROM THE NATIONAL COLLEGIATE
ATHLETIC ASSOCIATION THEY ARGUE
THAT OF COLLEGES HAD TO FUND
WOMEN'S ATHLETICS MORE THAN THEY
WERE ALREADY DOING.
THEN TITLE NINE WOULD
ESSENTIALLY DESTROY MAJOR
COLLEGE FOOTBALL AND BASKETBALL
PROGRAMS AT A TIME WHEN WOMEN'S
ATHLETIC PROGRAMS AND MOUNTED.
TO ABOUT 2% OF TOTAL COLLEGIATE
ATHLETIC BUDGETS.
THE TITLE NINE REGULATIONS WERE
NOT A TOP PRIORITY FOR
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH EDUCATION
AND WELFARE.
THE REGULATIONS BECAME EFFECTIVE
ON JULY.
TWENTY ONE NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
THE OFFICE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS WAS
CHARGED WITH THE ENFORCEMENT OF
TITLE NINE BUT WITHOUT THREATS
OF LOST FINANCIAL AID SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COLLEGES.
AND UNIVERSITIES SIMPLY HAVE
CHOSEN NOT TO ENFORCE THE
REGULATIONS THIS PRACTICE
CONTINUES TODAY AND IT IS MOSTLY
THROUGH LAWSUITS THAT ANY
PROGRESS IN COMPLIANCE HAS BEEN
MADE ONE CASE AT A TIME.
THE ENACTMENT OF TITLE NINE HAS
BEEN SUPPORTED IN CALIFORNIA BY
ACTIONS TAKEN THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
STARTING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
WHEN THE FIRST PIECE OF THE
GENDER EQUITY LAWS WERE ENACTED.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO EDUCATION
CODE ADDED THE SEX EQUITY AND
EDUCATION ACT PROVIDING
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK TO ADDRESS
GENDER DISCRIMINATION.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR DE
FINISH OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
NINETY TWO ADDED THE UNIFORM
COMPLAINT PROCEDURES NINETY
THREE GROUNDS FOR SUSPENSION AND
EXPULSION FOR ACTS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WERE AT IT.
ALSO IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
WRITTEN POLICIES ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
THE CURRENT HIGHER EDUCATION
PORTION IS IN THE EQUITY IN THE
HIGHER EDUCATION ACT WHICH
INCLUDES THE SEX EQUITY IN
EDUCATION.
IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN JACKIE SPEAR
INTRODUCED AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SIX TO ADD GENDER EQUITY TO THE
COORDINATED COMPLIANCE REVIEW
PROCESS CONDUCTED FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
RECEIVING STATE FUNDING IT
INCLUDES LANGUAGE THAT IT ONLY
IS REQUIRED TO BE IMPLEMENTED
WHEN SUFFICIENT FUNDS HAVE BEEN
APPROPRIATED WITHOUT ANY FUNDING
THE ON SITE REVIEWS WERE LIMITED
TO TWENTY PER YEAR.
AND AT THAT RATE WE WOULD NEVER
REALIZE FULL ENFORCEMENT OF
THESE LEGAL REQUIREMENTS.
I WAS HIRED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF
AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX I WORKED
WITH LEGAL COUNSEL TO DEVELOP
THE FIRST SEVEN TO EIGHT YEARS
OF THE COMPLIANCE PROGRAM.
THE PROCESS INCLUDES THREE HOUR
TRAINING SESSIONS FOR
RESPONSIBLE STAFF PRIOR TO THE
ONSITE REVIEW.
I STARTED CONDUCTING THESE
REVIEWS TWENTY TWO YEARS AFTER
THE PASSAGE OF TITLE.
NINE THERE WERE MULTIPLE NON
COMPLIANT FINDINGS FOR ALMOST
ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS THERE WERE
MANY SCHOOLS THAT STILL HAD
GENDER SEGREGATED PHYSICAL
EDUCATION CLASSES.
DURING ONE COMPLIANCE REVIEW A
MIDDLE SCHOOL PRINCIPAL KEPT
SAYING YOU'RE GOING OUT TO P. E.
RIGHT.
HE KNEW THAT SINGLE SEX OF P.
CLASSES WERE WRONG BUT HE WANTED
ME TO FORCE THE CHANGE FROM MY
COMPLIANCE REVIEW.
TITLE NINE COORDINATOR'S DIDN'T
KNOW HOW TO DO THEIR JOBS AND
DIDN'T FEEL EMPOWERED TO DO
THEIR JOBS THE STATE AND FEDERAL
LEGAL PROVISIONS WERE NOT BEING
IMPLEMENTED.
AFTER I LEFT THAT POSITION THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION COMBINED THE SEX
EQUITY IN EDUCATION ACT WITH
OTHER DISCRIMINATION PIECES AND
NOW.
IT IS LOCATED IN AN EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY SECTION I HAVE GREAT
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS SINCE THE
PROTECTIONS BASED ON GENDER ARE
NOW SURROUNDED BY ALL OF THE
OTHER DISCRIMINATION ISSUES.
EVEN WHEN GENDER EQUITY
PROVISIONS SAT ALONE GENDER
EQUITY HAD NOT BEEN ACHIEVED OR
MAINTAINED IN MOST OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS.
IN ADDITION THE ON SITE REVIEWS
HAVE BASICALLY BEEN REPLACED
WITH DOCUMENT REVIEWS WEAKENING
THE PREVIOUS COMPLIANCE PROCESS.
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE ON SITE REVIEWS THAT
WE CREATED.
BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR TO
WHAT IS BEING PROVIDED BY CD E.
NOW WITH DOCUMENT COMPLIANCE.
ASSUMPTIONS AND ATTITUDES THAT
PEOPLE HOLD ABOUT APPROPRIATE
FEMALE AND MALE ROLES JOBS AND
BEHAVIORS CANNOT BE CHANGED BY
LAW.
BUT THE RIGHTS PRIVILEGES
OPPORTUNITIES AND TREATMENT CAN
AND SHOULD BE EQUALIZED WHEN
GENDER STEREOTYPES GUIDE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMMING
DISCRIMINATION IS AT THE
PROGRAM'S ROUTE.
DISCRIMINATION CAN PLAY OUT IN
PRACTICES THAT VIOLATE STUDENTS
CIVIL RIGHTS WE ARE ALL
INDIVIDUALS AND LEARN IN
DIFFERENT WAYS IT IS INCORRECT
TO BELIEVE THE IDEA THAT THERE
ARE HARD WIRED DIFFERENCES.
BETWEEN BOYS AND GIRLS BRAINS.
EVERY STUDENT LEARNS BETTER WHEN
THE TEACHER USES DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES AND METHODS TO ENSURE
THAT EACH CHILD IN THE CLASSROOM
AS A FAIR CHANCE TO SUCCEED.
EQUITABLE TREATMENT OF ALL MALE
AND FEMALE STUDENTS FROM
PRESCHOOL THROUGH UNIVERSITY
WILL INCREASE FULFILLMENT OF
INDIVIDUAL POTENTIAL.
AS INDIVIDUALS EXPLORE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPRESS THEIR
TALENTS.
THE TRADITIONAL STEREOTYPES
BREAK DOWN AND CHANGE BASIC
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT GENDER
APPROPRIATE ROLES JOBS AND
BEHAVIORS.
THERE TRAINS THAT HAVE THEM HAD
THE MOST POSITIVE IMPACT ON MY
TEACHING.
WAS CALLED GENDER ETHNIC
EXPECTATIONS FOR STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT IT OPENED MY AYE
AYES TO GENDER FAIRNESS AND
CHANGE MY CLASSROOM PRACTICES SO
THAT I COULD CREATE CLASSROOMS
FREE OF BIAS.
I'M A STRONG PROPONENT OF
TRAINING TEACHERS TO CONDUCT
THEIR CLASSROOMS FREE FROM BIAS
RATHER THAN TURNING BACK TO
SINGLE GENDER CLASSES AND
SCHOOLS.
IT IS NOW FORTY SEVEN YEARS
SINCE TITLE NINE REGULATIONS
WERE IMPLEMENTED WHAT STILL
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED FOR ME ITS
ONGOING EDUCATION.
TRAININGS AND ENFORCEMENT
RECOMMENDATION.
ONE IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTY NINE
NO EIGHT ADDED SECTION TWO TO
FOUR POINT FIVE TO THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION COLD.
TRAIN THE TRAINERS GRANT PROGRAM
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION SHALL AWARD GRANTS
FROM FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR THE
PURPOSE. FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF PROGRAMS TO TRAIN TRAINERS
AND GENDER EQUITY THE WOULD
PROVIDE ONGOING GENDER TRAIN TO
ALL STAFF MEMBERS INCLUDING
CERTIFICATED IN CLASSIFIED.
AND MAINTAINING A POOL OF
KNOWLEDGEABLE GENDER EQUITY
TRAINERS.
AND EDUCATED STAFF WILL PROVIDE
A MORE FAIR AND EQUITABLE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
STUDENTS THE PROVISIONS OF AB
NINE OH EIGHT MUST BE FUNDED
EVERY YEAR.
WHEN THIS TITLE NINE AT FORTY
FIVE WAS PRODUCED BY THE
NATIONAL COALITION COALITION FOR
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN EDUCATION IT
WAS BEFORE BETSY DEVICE WAS
APPOINTED EDUCATION SECRETARY?
AS YOU REVIEW THE FULL REPORT
PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THAT ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SECOND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DEVICE HAD THE
DEPARTMENT RISKS IN MOST ALL
PREVIOUS SEXUAL HARASSMENT
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS.
THE ONLY DOCUMENT THAT SHE COULD
NOT RE STAN WAS THE TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE REVISED SEXUAL
HARASSMENT GUIDANCE.
THESE PREVIOUS DOCUMENTS PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED CLARIFICATION FOR
PREVENTING AND ADDRESSING TITLE
NINE ISSUES ON OUR VALUABLE TO
LOSE TOOLS.
THE NEW PROPOSED FEDERAL
REGULATIONS WILL REMOVE THE
SUGGESTED SIXTY DAYTIME FRAME TO
COMPLETE TITLE NINE
INVESTIGATIONS.
IT NO LONGER WOULD REQUIRE AN
EVIDENTIARY HEARING TO ALLOW FOR
INFORMAL RESOLUTION INCLUDING
MEDIATION. FOR INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION THE RECIPIENTS
GRIEVANCE PROCEDURE MUST PROVIDE
FOR A LIFE HEARING WHERE THE
WHERE THE DECISION MAKER MUST.
PERMIT EACH PARTY TO ASK THE
OTHER PARTY AND THEIR WITNESSES
ALL WROTE RELEVANT QUESTIONS
INCLUDING CHALLENGING AND
CREDIBILITY WHAT DOES THIS MEAN
FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS.
THERE IS ALREADY A HUGE UNDER
REPORTING OF SEXUAL.
HARASSMENT RAPE AND OTHER SEX
BASED DISCRIMINATION AND THIS
PROVISION WILL PRETTY MUCH
GUARANTEE THAT VICTIMS WILL NOT
COME FORWARD MAKE NO MISTAKE
DEVICES ACTIONS AMOUNT TO A
BLATANT ROLL BACK.
OF STRONG AND NECESSARY
PROTECTIONS FOR STUDENTS
SURVIVORS RECOMMENDATION TO A A
YOU W. STRONGLY SUPPORTS SP FOUR
NINETY THREE INTRODUCED BY
HANNAH BETH SENATOR HANNAH BETH
JACKSON.
ON FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN THIS COMPREHENSIVE BILL
PROVIDES THE PROTECTIONS FOR
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
ASSAULT THAT WILL BE NEEDED FOR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
THAT RECEIVE STATE FUNDS THE
STATE BILL SPECIFICALLY PROVIDES
FOR STUDENTS TO NOT BE SUBJECTED
TO ANY FORM OF DIRECT LIFE CROSS
EXAMINATION FROM THE ACCUSED
SIDE.
RECOMMENDATION THREE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO REVIEW THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PROTECTIONS AN AD
CODE FOR STUDENTS IN K.. TWELVE
TO SEE IF NEW LEGISLATION IS
NEEDED TO STRENGTHEN THOSE
PROTECTIONS.
EVERY DISTRICT COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY IS REQUIRED TO HAVE
AT LEAST ONE TITLE NINE
COORDINATOR THAT PERSON MUST BE
FULLY TRAINED AND SUPPORTED TO
FULFILL THE LEGAL REQUIREMENTS.
THE ROLE OF TITLE NINE
COORDINATOR'S COMPLEX AND SHOULD
BE A FULL TIME POSITION UNDER A
DISTRICT OR SCHOOL.
SO THEY CAN MAINTAIN COMPLIANCE.
ACT EMENDATION FOR I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT IN CALIFORNIA TO
CHANGE THE NAME FROM TITLE NINE
COORDINATOR TO THE GENDER EQUITY
COORDINATOR. TO BE SURE THAT
STATE LAWS AND REGULATIONS ARE
NOT OVERLOOKED.
RECOMMENDATION FIVE ALL TITLE
NINE GENDER EQUITY COORDINATORS
MUST BE CONSIDERED AS LEADERS
AND COLLABORATORS AND BE
PROACTIVE GENDER EQUITY
ADMINISTRATORS FOR THEIR
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS.
THEY MUST HAVE THE EXPERTISE
AUTHORITY ON TIME BUILT INTO
THEIR WORK SCHEDULE TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH ALL ASPECTS.
OF QUALITY PLAN TO ADDRESS
GENDER FAIRNESS IS TO CREATE
TEAMS OF GENDER EQUITY
COORDINATORS WITH EXPERTISE IN
DIFFERENT AREAS.
THE SENATE IS A BRANCH OF A A
YOU W. AS A TITLE NINE FOCUS
GROUP AND HAS BEEN HOSTING TITLE
NINE COORDINATOR'S ROUNDTABLE
CALLS.
THEY INVITE ALL TITLE NINE
COORDINATORS FOR SANTA CLARA
COUNTY TO ATTEND.
EACH OF THE ROUND TABLE CALLS
HAS A PRESENTER THAT HAS
EXPERTISE IN TITLE NINE WHETHER
PRACTITIONERS OR ATTORNEYS. TO
ENSURE STUDENT SUCCESS IN
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITIES WE MUST
BEGIN AND CONTINUE FROM
PRESCHOOL THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATING ALL STUDENTS ON THEIR
RIGHTS.
THERE'S A REAL CONTINUE ON HERE
IN EQUITY IN SCHOOLS MUST BEGIN
WITH THE YOUNGEST OF CHILDREN
ALL STUDENTS MUST LEARN TO
RESPECT.
EACH PERSON AS AN INDIVIDUAL NOT
AS A FEMALE OR A MALE.
SO WE CAN PROTECT ALL CHILDREN
FROM DISCRIMINATION HARASSMENT
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY -- IF I GIVE IT.
TO GREAT THANK YOU MISS THAT MAN
I WANNA I'M AT THIS POINT ALSO
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RICHARD BLOOM I'M TO THIS JOINT
HEARING -- AND IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING YOU WOULD LIKE TO SAY
OR IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
MS HAT -- SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY -- NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
LARA FAIR OF THE BUREAU OF
CHILDREN'S JUSTICE.
IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT
SECTION WITHIN THE OFFICE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SHE HAS THE DISTINCTION OF BEING
THE FORMER REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR
THE FEDERAL OFFICE OF CIVIL
RIGHTS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING CIVIL
RIGHTS COMPLIANCE IN CALIFORNIA
AND IS RATHER UNIQUELY QUALIFIED
TO SPEAK ON TODAY'S TOPIC -- SO
WITH THAT I INVITE YOU -- TO
SHARE YOUR TESTIMONY AND I ASK
THAT YOU LOOK UP FROM TIME TO
TIME -- AT OUR TIME KEEPER
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE IN
CHAIRS.
ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAVE YOU EVER SAID I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS FEDERAL AND STATE
LAWS ADDRESSING GENDER EQUITY IN
OUR SCHOOLS.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITY.
THIS IS AN AREA OF INCREDIBLE
IMPORTANCE TO ATTORNEY GENERAL
ETCETERA.
AS WE GET INTO THE SPECIFICS I
WILL DISCUSS SOME OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WORK IN
THIS AREA.
AND BECAUSE OF TITLE NINE STEPS
AND BRATS AND AS YOU JUST HEARD
THE SIMILAR DEPTH AND BREADTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S ANTI DISCRIMINATION
LAWS INCLUDING THE SEX EQUITY IN
EDUCATION ACT.
MY COMMENTS TODAY WILL ADDRESS
ONLY SOME OF THE TOPICS THAT
THESE LAWS COVER.
SPECIFICALLY I WILL BE TOUCHING
ON CHANGES BOTH PROPOSED AND
IMPLEMENTED AND HOW TITLE NINE
IS INTERPRETED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA LAW AND FEDERAL LAW
WITH RESPECT TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND VIOLENCE.
AND ALSO DOMESTIC AND DATING
VIOLENCE IN STOCK IN OUR SCHOOLS.
THE DEFINITION OF SEX AND ITS
IMPORTANCE.
APPLICATION OF THE LAW TO EQUITY
IN ATHLETICS AND FINALLY THE
SCOPE OF THE LOST COVERAGE FOR
OUR STUDENTS AND STAFF WHO ARE
TRAVELING AND WORKING ABROAD.
LET ME BEGIN BY PROVIDING SOME
BACKGROUND ON FEDERAL TITLE NINE
AS YOU HEARD TITLE NINE MANDATES
THAT NO STUDENT SHALL ON THE
BASIS OF SEX BE DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST.
IN AN EDUCATION PROGRAM OR
ACTIVITY THAT RECEIVES FEDERAL
EDUCATION FUNDING.
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
EFFECTUATE THIS ANTI
DISCRIMINATION MANDATE BY
ISSUING REGULATIONS AND GUIDANCE
AND CREATING THE NATION WIDE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM ADMINISTERED
BY THE OFFICE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS.
TITLE NINE APPLIES TO ALL AREAS
OF AN EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES AND THAT
INCLUDES RECRUITMENT.
ADMISSIONS HOUSING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE ATHLETICS ACCESS TO
COURSES AND CLASSES AND REPORTS
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT VIOLENCE.
IT PROHIBITS DISCRIMINATION ON
THE BASIS OF SEX MARITAL STATUS
PREGNANCY AND CONDITIONS OF
PREGNANCY AGAINST OUR STUDENTS
AND OUR STAFF AND THESE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
FIRST AS YOU KNOW EQUAL ACCESS
TO EDUCATION AND EDUCATIONAL
ACTIVITIES ARE TOO OFTEN DENIED
BECAUSE A STUDENT HAS BEEN
SUBJECTED TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
OR VIOLENCE ON THE BASIS OF SEX.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE IN A TIME
OF INSTABILITY WITH RESPECT TO
TITLE NINE REQUIREMENTS FOR
PREVENTION AND REDRESS OF ACTS
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT INSULT. FOR
THE PAST TWENTY PLUS YEARS TITLE
NINE WAS INTERPRETED IN THE
FOLLOWING WAYS.
IT REQUIRED SCHOOLS COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT COMPLAINT PROCEDURES
PROVIDING FOR A PROMPT AND
GLOBAL RESPONSE TO ANY REPORTS
ORAL WRITTEN OBSERVED OR
EXPERIENCED OF DISCRIMINATION
HARASSMENT.
OR VIOLENCE ON THE BASIS OF SEX.
IT PROHIBITED UNWELCOME CONDUCT
OF A SEXUAL NATURE THAT IS
SUFFICIENTLY SERIOUS SO SEVERE
PROGRESSIVE OR PERSISTENT THAT
CREATES A HOSTILE ENVIRONMENT ON
OUR CAMPUS OR IT LIMITS
EDUCATIONAL ACCESS.
INCLUDING WHERE THE HARASSMENT
OR SALT MAY HAVE FIRST OCCURRED
OFF CAMPUS.
IT REQUIRES SCHOOLS THAT KNEW OR
REASONABLY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT VIOLENCE
IMPACTING OUR STUDENTS TO ACT
REASONABLY PROMPTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY IN TAKING STEPS TO
IN THAT HARASSMENT.
PREVENTED FOR CURRENTS AND
REDRESS ITS EFFECTS ON THE
VICTIMS AN AS NEEDED OUR SCHOOL
COMMUNITY.
AND IMPORTANTLY WITH SOME
EXCEPTIONS FOR CONFIDENTIAL
COUNSELORS AND STAFF ANY SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES WHO RECEIVE NOTICE OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR VIOLENCE
AND WHO WAS STUDENT COULD
REASONABLY BELIEVE.
HAD THE AUTHORITY TO TAKE SOME
ACTION WAS REQUIRED TO
IMMEDIATELY REPORT SO THAT THE
SCHOOL'S RESPONSE COULD BE BOTH
PROMPT.
AND EFFECTIVE.
HOWEVER ON NOVEMBER SIXTEENTH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION UNDER
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ISSUED
ITS PROPOSED SIGNIFICANT AND
SWEEPING AMENDMENTS TO THE
IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS FOR
TITLE.
NINE IN A NOTICE OF PROPOSED
RULEMAKING.
IN RESPONSE ON JANUARY THIRTIETH
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
SUBMITTED A MULTI STATE COMMENT
LETTER URGING THE COMPLETE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE PROPOSED
REGULATIONS BECAUSE THEY SO
SEVERELY UNDERMINE THE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION PROTECTIONS OF
TITLE.
NINE AND CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO
ENSURE THAT IT SCHOOLS ARE FREE
FROM HARASSMENT.
OUR COMMENT LETTER SEVENTY ONE
PAGES SO HIGHLIGHTED HERE TODAY
ARE ONLY SOME OF THE RULES
PROPOSED CHANGES.
FIRST THE PROPOSED RULES
DRAMATICALLY NARROW TITLE NINES
DEFINITION OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
BY ONLY PROTECTING AGAINST
CONDUCT BUT A VICTIM CAN SHOW TO
BE SEVERE.
PERVASIVE AND ALSO OBJECTIVELY
OFFENSIVE.
NOW UNDER THE PROPOSED RULE
SCHOOLS WOULD ONLY NEED TO TAKE
ACTION IF THE TITLE NINE QUARTER
OR AN INDIVIDUAL WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO ACTUALLY PUNISH THE
PERPETRATOR.
RECEIVES ACTUAL KNOWLEDGE.
SO IF AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
STUDENT REPORTS OF SEXUAL
ONLY A SECURITY GUARD OR A COACH
OR IF THE SEXUAL ASSAULT IS
PERPETRATED BY A PRINCIPAL FOR
EXAMPLE AT A SCHOOL ITSELF.
BUT NOT REPORTED TO THE
SUPERINTENDENT OR TITLE NINE
COORDINATOR THE SCHOOL WOULD NO
LONGER BE REQUIRED TO ACT UNDER
TITLE.
NINE THE PROPOSED RULES HOLD
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
RESPONSIBLE ONLY IF THE RESPONSE
IS FOUND TO BE DELIBERATELY
DIFFERENT TO KNOWN AXE.
THIS MEANS INTENTIONAL AND
CLEARLY AND REASONABLE IN LIGHT
OF KNOWN CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT'S AN EXTREMELY HARD STANDARD
TO MEET AND IT'S HIGH AND
EXACTING.
FURTHER IF A SEXUALLY HOSTILE
ENVIRONMENT ON THE BASIS OF SEX
IS FOUND THE PROPOSED RULES NO
WORK NO LONGER REQUIRED
EDUCATION INSTITUTION TO TAKE%
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO EFFECTIVELY
ELIMINATE THAT HOSTILE
ENVIRONMENT PRINTS.
PREVENT ITS RECURRENCE AND
ADDRESS IT'S A FAX.
THEY ALSO HAVE YOU HEARD ALLOWED
FOR IN PERSON CROSS EXAMINATION
OF SURVIVORS BY AN ADVISER WHO
SELECTED BY THE OTHER PARTY.
OR THE ACCUSED.
WITHOUT IDENTIFYING LIMITATIONS
TO PREVENT RETIREMENT IS ATION
OR FURTHER HARASSMENT.
THE RULES GENERALLY ALSO REQUIRE
A FORMAL WRITTEN SIGNED
COMPLAINT WITH A SPECIFIC
REQUEST FOR AN INVESTIGATION TO
BE FILED WITH THE TITLE NINE
COORDINATOR TO RECEIVE A FULL
INVESTIGATION.
AND THIS IS SO EVEN IN OUR K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS REPORTS
ARE OFTEN ORAL.
AND BY YOUNG STUDENTS MANY OF
WHOM WILL NOT KNOW THAT THEY
NEED TO MEET THIS WRITTEN
REQUIREMENT TO OBTAIN RELIEF.
THE PROPOSED RULES ALSO PROHIBIT
TITLE NINE'S PROTECTIONS FROM
APPLYING IF THE HARASSING
CONDUCT DID NOT OCCUR TO THE
STUDENT WITH IN THE EDUCATION
PROGRAM OR ACTIVITY.
THIS CHANGES OUT OF TOUCH WITH
HOW SEXUAL ASSAULT IMPACTS
STUDENT ON CAMPUS.
AS US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ITSELF EXPLAINED IN FEDERAL
COURT BRIEFING WHEN ASSESSING
WHETHER OFF CAMPUS SEXUAL%
ASSAULT CREATES A HOSTILE%
ENVIRONMENT ON CAMPUS.
COURTS HAVE RECOGNIZED THE
PERNICIOUS EFFECTS ARE NOT
LIMITED TO THE EVENT ITSELF AND
CAN PERMEATE THE EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT.
FINALLY THE PROPOSED RULES
REQUIRE THE SCHOOL OVERALL TODAY
MISS DISMISS ANY COMPLAINT THAT
DOES NOT MEET THESE NEW
HEIGHTENED REQUIREMENTS.
CALIFORNIA LAW INCORPORATES
TITLE NINE STATUTORY AND
REGULATORY CREDIT REQUIREMENTS
SO IF THE REPROACH TO PROPOSE
RULES BECOME FINAL THESE CHANGES
TO THE REGULATIONS MADE BY THE
US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WOULD
BECOME PART OF CALIFORNIA LAW.
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA LAW ALSO
STATES THAT CONSISTENT
INTERPRETATION WITH TITLE NINE
IS NOT INTENDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE WHERE CALIFORNIA LAW
PROVIDES FOR MORE PROTECTIONS OR
IMPOSES ADDITIONAL OBLIGATIONS.
AND AS YOU JUST HEARD CALIFORNIA
LAW DOES PROVIDE MORE
PROTECTIONS AND IMPOSE
ADDITIONALOBLIGATIONS THAN
TITLE NINE IN SOME OF THE
FOLLOWING WAYS NOT ALL LISTED
HERE FOR TIME REASONS.
FIRST IT REQUIRES COMPREHENSIVE
SEXUAL VIOLENCE PREVENTION
TRAINING FOR STUDENTS.
SECOND TO PROVIDE A BROADER AND
MORE PROTECTIVE DEFINITION OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THEN THE
CURRENT AND PROPOSED US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
DEFINITIONS.
THIRD AND POST ACT SECONDARY
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS THAT
RECEIVE STATE FUNDS FOR THE
OFFENSES OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DATING
VIOLENCE AND STALKING.
CALIFORNIALAW HAS ESTABLISHED A
STRONG AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT
STANDARD.
AND REQUIRES APPLICATION OF THE
PREPONDERANCE OF THE EVIDENCE
STANDARD.
IT ALSO ESTABLISH PROCEDURES FOR
KEEPING VICTIMS INFORMED OF THE
STATUS OF DISCIPLINARY
PROCEEDINGS.
WRITTEN NOTIFICATION ABOUT ON
AND OFF CAMPUS RESOURCES AND
TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING FOR OUR
CAMPUS INVESTIGATORS.
IN THIS AREA OF INTERPRETATION
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF BOTH
CALIFORNIAN FEDERAL LAW ARE
IMPORTANT TO THE SUCCESS OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS.
BECAUSE WHEN NOT PREVENTED OR
PROPERLY ADDRESS SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND VIOLENCE CAN HAVE
A DEBILITATING IMPACT ON A
STUDENTS ACCESS TO EDUCATION.
AND AS YOU HEARD THERE IS
ALREADY A SERIOUS LACK OF
REPORTING ON THESE ASSAULTS.
DUE TO REASONS SUCH AS FEAR OF
REPRISAL. FOR THE HARASSMENT AND
LACK OF KNOWLEDGE ABOUT HOW TO
OBTAIN REDRESS.
I'M GOING TO TURN TO THE
DEFINITION OF SEX AND GENDER
UNDER CALIFORNIA AND FEDERAL
LAWS.
TITLE NINE REQUIRE STUDENTS TO
BE PROVIDED AN EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT FREE FROM
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON JUST ONE
EXPLICITLY IDENTIFIED CáC
PROTECTED CATEGORY AND THAT IS.
SIX WHILE MANY COURTS HAVE
CONCLUDED THE TITLE NINE'S
PROTECTIONS AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION ALSO PROTECTS
STUDENTS BASED ON GENDER
IDENTITY.
OR BECAUSE OF THEIR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
THE SUPREME COURT HAS NOT TAKEN
UP THESE ISSUES YET.
ALSO THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS NOT RECOGNIZE THE
TITLE NINE ENCOMPASSES
DISCRIMINATION ON THE BASIS OF
SEXUAL ORIENTATION EVEN THOUGH
AGENCIES LIKE THE EEOC.
HAVE REACHED THIS CONCLUSION FOR
EMPLOYEES OUR SCHOOLS WHO ARE
PROTECTED UNDER TITLE SEVEN OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT.
FURTHER IN FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION RESCINDED THE
PROTECTIVE GUIDANCE FOR
TRANSGENDER STUDENTS THERE WAS
ISSUED IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
THE RESCINDED GUIDANCE ADVISE
THE TITLE NINE PROTECT STUDENTS
WERE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
EXCLUDED DENIED BENEFITS ARE
SEPARATED ON THE BASIS OF THEIR
GENDER IDENTITY AND THEIR
TRANSGENDER STATUS.
IN COMPARISON CALIFORNIA LAWS GO
MUCH FURTHER.
THEY SPECIFICALLY AND EXPLICITLY
PROTECT AGAINST DISCRIMINATION
ON THE BASIS OF SEX GENDER
GENDER IDENTITY GENDER
EXPRESSION AND SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
FURTHERMORE THAT CALIFORNIA LAW
PROHIBITS GENDER EXPRESSION
DISCRIMINATION IS ADDITIONALLY
REPORT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IN THE
PROPOSED TITLE NINE REGULATIONS
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
HAS INDICATED THAT IT IS
STEPPING AWAY.
FROM PROTECTIONS FOR STUDENTS
WHO HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED TO
DISCRIMINATION ON THE BASIS OF
SEX STEREOTYPING.
IN CONTRAVENTION OF SUPREME
COURT PRECEDENTS AND THE TEXT OF
TITLE NINE THE PROPOSED
REGULATIONS WOULD NO LONGER
PROHIBIT EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS FROM USING AND
DISTRIBUTING MATERIALS THAT
PROMOTE OR PERPETUATE SEX
STEREOTYPES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE MAILING OUT
RECRUITMENT FLYERS IDENTIFYING
ONLY MEN IN OUR STEM CAREERS AND
ONLY WOMEN IN THEATER AND DANCE.
COULD BE PERMISSIBLE.
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS ALSO DO
NOT STATE THAT HARASSMENT ON THE
BASIS OF SEX MAIN COMPASS
HARASSMENT BECAUSE A STUDENT
FAILS TO CONFORM TO THOSE SEX
STEREOTYPES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE A YOUNG BOY WHOSE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BECAUSE HE
WEARS HIS HAIR LONG OR LIKES TO
WEAR NOW NAIL POLISH MAY NOT BE
PROTECTED UNDER THE PROPOSED
REGULATIONS.
IT IS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO ENFORCE ITS OWN
LAWS AND PROVIDE SIMPLE AND
EXPEDITIOUS WAYS FOR LESBIAN GAY
BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER QUEER AND
GENDER NON CONFORMING STUDENTS
AND THEIR PARENTS AND GUARDIANS.
TO OBTAIN RELIEF.
THIS IS AN AREA OF IMPORTANCE
FOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JUST
RECENTLY ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN OUR
OFFICE JOIN TWENTY OTHER
ATTORNEYS GENERAL AN AMICUS
BRIEF IN SUPPORT OF A
TRANSGENDER STUDENT WHO IS SUING.
THE ST JOHNS COUNTY FLORIDA
SCHOOL BOARD UNDER TITLE NINE
BECAUSE THAT BOARDS POLICY
PROHIBITS TRANSGENDER CHILDREN
FROM USING RESTROOMS THAT
CORRELATE WITH THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY.
AND AMONG OTHER THINGS ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S ARGUED IN THE AMICUS
BRIEF THAT PROTECTING DRENCHED
TREND OR TRANSGENDER RIGHTS
CONFERS BROAD SOCIAL BENEFITS
WELL CREATING NO PUBLIC SAFETY.
THREAT AND IMPOSING NOTE
MEANINGFUL FINANCIAL BURDEN.
NEXT I WILL TURN TO GENDER AND
SEX EQUITY IN ATHLETICS.
AND IN A NUMBER OF WAYS
CALIFORNIA'S LAW HAS BEEN
MODELED AFTER THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION GUIDANCE AND
FEDERAL COURT FEDERAL COURT
DECISIONS AND INTERPRET TITLE
NINE PROTECTIONS IN THIS AREA.
CALIFORNIA IN FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES DO NOT HOLD THAT
SEPARATE FACILITIES TEAMS AND
CONDITIONS FOR PLAY ARE
INHERENTLY UNEQUAL.
RATHER CALIFORNIAN FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES SAY GENERALLY AS YOU
HEARD THAT SEPARATE IS PERMITTED
IN SPORTS FOR FEMALES AND MALES
SO LONG AS SUBSTANTIALLY EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY WITH RESPECT TO BOTH
THE CONDITIONS.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY IS
PROVIDED FOR MEMBERS OF BOTH
SEXES.
UNDER FEDERAL AND STATE LAW WITH
RESPECT TO THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FEMALES AND MALES TO PLAY A
SPORT.
A SCHOOL'S ATHLETICS PROGRAM
MUST EFFECTIVELY ACCOMMODATE THE
INTERESTS AND ABILITIES OF
MEMBERS OF BOTH SEXES BY MEETING
ONE OF A THREE PART TEST.
AND THE FIRST PART.
PROVIDE ATHLETIC OPPORTUNITIES
TO MALE AND FEMALE STUDENTS
THERE ARE SUBSTANTIALLY
PROPORTIONATE TO THEIR OVERALL
ENROLLMENT AND THE SECOND.
THE SCHOOL COULD SHOW A HISTORY
AND CONTINUING PRACTICE OF
EXPANDING OPPORTUNITIES
RESPONSIVE TO THE INTERESTS OF
THE UNDERREPRESENTED SEX OR IN
THE THIRD A SCHOOL COULD SHOW
THAT AVAILABLE OPPORTUNITIES AT
THE INSTITUTION FULLY AND
EFFECTIVELY MEET THE INTERESTS
AND ABILITIES.
OF THE UNDERREPRESENTED SEX.
AND AS A NUMBER OF STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THIS SEPARATE BUT EQUAL
LEGAL FRAMEWORK HAS RESULTED IN
IMPROVEMENTS FOR WOMEN IN TERMS
OF ACCESS TO SPORTS.
MORE EQUITABLE FACILITIES AND
EQUIPMENT SCHOLARSHIPS HOWEVER
AS I'M SURE OTHERS SPEAKERS
TODAY WILL SHARE ENSURING EQUITY
IN ATHLETICS REQUIRES CONSTANT
VIGILANCE AND VIGOROUS OVERSIGHT
AND ENFORCEMENT.
BECAUSE CONDITIONS WITH RESPECT
TO FILL FACILITIES STUDENTS
INTERESTS AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PLAY AMONG OTHER THINGS CHANGE
FROM YEAR TO YEAR.
IN ANY SCHOOL COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY.
FURTHER WITH RESPECT TO IDENTIFY
TO FIND WHETHER ANY QUALITY
STILL EXISTS THE FEDERAL EQUITY
IN EDUCATION ATHLETICS
DISCLOSURE ACT REQUIRES ANNUAL
REPORTING BY A POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
ON PARTICIPATION STAFFING
REVENUE AND EXPENSES BY OUR
MEN'S AND WOMEN'S TEAMS.
AND FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE BASED
ON LEGISLATION RECENTLY PASSED
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES SITE
LEVEL REPORTING OF PRECIPITATION
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL.
AND THESE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
CAN PROVIDE US WITH INITIAL
INFORMATION REGARDING WHETHER
SEPARATE IS EQUITABLE.
HOWEVER NEITHER SET OF REPORTS
IS SUBJECT TO ON SITE OR OTHER
AUDITING.
FEDERAL LAW PROVIDES FOR IN
CALIFORNIA LAW REINFORCES THE
REQUIREMENT FOR TITLE NINE OR
GENDER EQUITY COORDINATOR TO BE
DESIGNATED FOR EACH DISTRICT
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY IN THE
STATE.
AND AS YOU HEARD THIS PERSON IS
CHARGED WITH ASSESSING AND
COORDINATING COMPLIANCE AND
INVESTIGATING COMPLAINTS UNDER
TITLE.
NINE HOWEVER BECAUSE IN MANY OF
OUR SCHOOLS THE DUTIES OF A
COORDINATOR ARE VAST AND MYRIAD.
AND INCLUDE RESPONSIBILITIES
OTHER THAN TITLE NINE AND GENDER
EQUITY WE MAY NOT ALWAYS HAVE
SOMEONE AT THE SCHOOL LEVEL WITH
EXPERTISE AND SUFFICIENT TIME TO
ASSESS WHETHER FOR EXAMPLE.
THE INTERESTS AND ABILITIES TEST
HAS BEEN MAX ORDERING CONDUCT
THE IMPORTANT ASSESSMENT OF THE
ATHLETIC PROGRAMS COMPONENTS TO
SEE WHETHER IN FACT EQUITY HAS
BEEN ACHIEVED.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE FEDERAL
LAW THAT THE STATE HAS MERIT
RETAIN SOME PRESUMPTIONS OF AN
EQUALITY FOR WOMEN. FOR EXAMPLE
IF THERE WAS ONLY A BOYS
BASKETBALL TEAM AT A SCHOOL IN A
YOUNG GIRL WANTED TO PLAY VEN
IF SHE HAS THE SKILLS SHE WOULD
NOT HAVE A RIGHT UNDER
CALIFORNIA FEDERAL LAW BECAUSE
THERE'S AN EXCEPTION EQUAL
ACCESS. FOR SPORTS IDENTIFIED AS
CONTACT SPORTS.
FINALLY I WANT TO KNOW THAT
TITLE NINE SPECIFIC COVERAGE IS
LIMITED TO DISCRIMINATION IN THE
UNITED STATES. FOR STUDENTS AND
FACULTY WHO PARTICIPATE AND
TEACH AND A STUDY ABROAD PROGRAM
THE FEDERAL PROTECTIONS AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT ON
THE BASIS OF SEX DO NOT APPLY.
CALIFORNIA LAW DOES NOT SPECIFY
AND IT'S TAX WHETHER THERE IS A
SIMILAR JURISDICTIONAL LIMIT.
ON BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR TAKING UP THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC.
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU SO WITH MEMBER.
OF KAMALO THEIR DOLLS FOR A TIME
IN THE MEETING WHEN BOTH MEDINA
AND HIGH WORK.
BE AT THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE BUT WE'RE WE'RE DONE
WITH THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
AND THE REVENUE AND TAX
COMMITTEES SO THE FULL
DISCLOSURE I BE WITH YOU.
GOOD FOR FOR THE REST OF THE DAY
HERE.
AND ALSO ON THE I RECOGNIZE --
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF BLOOM FOR
JOINING US THIS AFTERNOON -- ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE DAY AS SEEN
KNOWN -- THE STAFF REMIND ME
THAT I HAVE I DO HAVE FUN SCHOOL
CAN IT COULD I ASK YOU.
TO COME BACK AND AND AND I'LL
TRY TO BE QUICK.
YEAH DID THE QUESTION IS GIVEN
THAT THE CALIFORNIA LAW DO NOT
ALWAYS AS STAND ALONE.
AND INSTEAD OF REFERENCING TO A
TITLE NIGHT.
SHOULD WE AMEND THOSE LAWS TO
QUALIFIED -- PROTECTIONS SAID
THAT THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION NO LONGER PROVIDES.
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
WELCOMES AND UNDERGOING DIALOGUE
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN THIS
AREA -- IN LIGHT OF THE PROS
REGULATIONS -- AS I DISCUSSED
BEFORE -- THE CALIFORNIA LAW
SAYS THAT WHERE YOU SPECIFICALLY
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS
OR YOU POSE ADDITIONAL
OBLIGATIONS THOSE CAN BE READ TO
BE ABOVE AND BEYOND.
FEDERAL REGULATIONS AND TITLE
NINE ITSELF SO IN THOSE AREAS
ONE AREA FOR FURTHER
CLARIFICATION MAYBE -- TO MORE
EXPLICITLY INCORPORATE THOSE
AREAS THAT YOU THINK ARE
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT -- IN AREAS
THAT YOU THINK -- SHOULD BE
SHORED UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NO WE MOVE TO THE NEXT
ONE IS.
THE KIND THOSE -- WAS HIGHER
EDUCATION LEADERS.
WHO CAN SPEAK TO THEIR --
CHALLENGES.
IN THE AND OPPOSED BY ENFORCING
TITLE.
NINE AND WE HAVE -- SU SAYING
TAYLOR.
LOOK LOOK LINDA WHO.
AND PETER KHôNG.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
I'M SORRY.
I'M SUZANNE TAYLOR I. IN THE
SYSTEM MIGHT HAD ONLINE CORNY OR
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN AS YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT OF DEVELOPMENTS IN
THE TITLE NINE WORLD SOUND
IMPORTANCE AND CHANGES IN A LOT
OF UNCERTAINTY AND SO I'M GLAD
THAT WE ALL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO UPDATE YOU.
ON HERE TODAY.
YOU SEE AS A NUMBER OF SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED TITLE
NINE RULES MANY OF WHICH DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL FAIR I'M
HIGHLIGHTED IN HER PRESENTATION.
AND AS LARA STATED THE RULES
WOULD NARROW THE DEFINITION OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ALSO
LIMóN APPLICATION OF SCHOOLS
TITLE NINE GRIEVANCE PROCEDURES
TO COMPLAINTS THAT MEET CERTAIN
ADDITIONAL THRESHOLD
REQUIREMENTS.
AND I JUST PUT A NOTE THAT WE
HAVE OTHER OBLIGATIONS OF BOTH
ETHICAL AND LEGAL TO RESPOND TO
MUCH OF THE BEHAVIOR THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION PROPOSES
EXCLUDING FROM TITLE.
AND SO ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS IF THE RULES ARE
ON ISSUED IN THEIR CURRENT FORM.
IS DEVELOPING PARALLEL PROCESSES
ONE FOR ADDRESSING SEXUAL%
HARASSMENT THAT WOULD FALL UNDER
TITLE LINE AND ONE FOR DRESSING
CONDUCT THAT WOULD NOT -- AND
THAT OBVIOUSLY HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO BE BOTH BURDENSOME TO OUR
SYSTEMS AND CONFUSING TO OUR
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT WE TRY VERY HARD TO AVOID.
AND IT'S ALSO BEEN NOTED THAT
THE RULES WOULD REQUIRE LIVE
HEARINGS AT WHICH PARTY'S
REPRESENTATIVES CONDUCT CROSS
EXAMINATION.
AND I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS REQUIREMENT WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY DISADVANTAGED
PARTIES WHO DON'T HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES OR WHOSE
REPRESENTATIVES ARE NOT
ADEQUATELY PREPARED TO CONDUCT
THE SORT OF ADVERSARIAL CROSS
EXAMINATION ARE QUESTIONING THE
DEPARTMENT APPARENTLY ENVISIONS.
SO THIS REQUIREMENT WOULD
CREATED IT AND INEQUITY IN THE
PROCESS AND THEN PUT THE ONUS ON
SCHOOLS TO CORRECT THAT AND
EQUITY.
AND I'M NOT GONNA GO INTO
FURTHER DETAILS ABOUT OUR
CONCERNS WITH THE TITLE NINE
RULES DUE TO TIME BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT YOU SEE HAS
TAKEN A VERY STRONG STANCE
AGAINST PARTS OF THE PROPOSED
RULES AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT.
AND AT THIS POINT WE OBVIOUSLY
DON'T KNOW WHEN THE RULES WILL
BE ISSUED OR WHAT THEY WILL
ULTIMATELY REQUIRE -- AND SO
WE'RE IN A LITTLE BIT OF A
HOLDING PATTERN ON THAT FRONT.
IN THE MEANTIME THIS PAST
JANUARY A CALIFORNIA COURT OF
APPEAL DECIDED A CASE WITH
IMPORTANT IMPLICATIONS FOR
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
SPECIFICALLY THE COURT RULED
THAT WHEN A SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
MATTER MAY RESULT IN SERIOU
SANCTIONS FOR A STUDENT
RESPONDENT AND CREDIBILITY
ESSENTIAL TO THE TO THE CASE XIN.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES MUST
HOLD A HUGE LIFE HEARING AT
WHICH THE RESPONDENT IS ALLOWED
TO QUESTION THE COMPLAINT AND
KEY WITNESSES AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAD NOT
PREVIOUSLY BEEN ARTICULATED BY
THE COURTS.
AND THIS IS SERIOUS IMPLICATIONS
FOR YOU SEE BECAUSE FOR REASONS
LIKE EXPLAIN IF YOU WISH WE HAVE
BEEN USING AN INVESTIGATIVE
MODEL RATHER THAN HEARING MODEL
TO RESOLVE OUR COMPLAINTS.
AND UNDER THAT MODEL THE
INVESTIGATOR INTERVIEWS THE
RESPONDENT AND THE COMPLAINANT
SEPARATELY AND THE PARTIES MAKE
QUESTION EACH OTHER AS WELL AS
WITNESSES BUT THE QUESTIONS ARE
ASKED BY THE INVESTIGATOR DURING
INVESTIGATIVE PHASE.
AND WHILE PARTY'S COULD APPEAL
THE OUTCOME OF THE PROCESS WHICH
MIGHT RESULT IN THE HEARING
THERE WAS NO APPEAL OR HEARING
AS A MATTER OF RIGHT.
SO WHILE WE'RE WAITING TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE TITLE LINE
RULES WE HAD TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
STEPS TO COMPLY WITH THIS COURT
RULING.
AND WE AT UC APPROACH THIS WITH
THE PRIMARY GOALS OF PROTECTING
BOTH THE PARTIES AND THE
INTEGRITY OF THE PROCESS.
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WE HAVE DONE
IS REVISE OUR STUDENTS YOU TO
CATIA AND PROCESS HER FRAMEWORK
TO PROVIDE BOTH PARTIES
COMPLAINTS AND RESPONDENTS.
THE RIGHT TO AN EVIDENTIARY
HEARING IN ANY CASE RESULTING IN
SUSPENSION OR DISMISSAL.
NOW WE KNOW THE PROSPECT OF A
LIVE HEARING IS INTIMIDATING TO
PARTIES AND PARTICULARLY FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S WRESTLING WITH THE
ALREADY DIFFICULT DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER TO COME FORWARD AT ALL.
AND SO WE'RE Q. AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING THEIR
WELL BEING IN THE PROCESS.
SOME OF THE THINGS WE'VE DONE TO
MITIGATE POTENTIAL HARM TO
PARTIES -- FROM THIS CROSS
EXAMINATION IS -- HAVE THE
QUESTIONING CONDUCTED BY THE
APPEAL BODY SO NOT BY THE
PARTIES ARE THE REPRESENTATIVES.
ALLOW THE PARTIES TO HAVE
SUPPORT PERSONS ALLOW THE
PARTIES TO BE VISUALLY OR
PHYSICALLY SEPARATED DURING
CROSS EXAMINATION AND THESE ARE
THINGS THE COURT IS SIGNIFIED
ARE ACCEPTABLE.
NOW WHILE THIS INTERIM PROCESS
AND IS IN PLACE WERE ALSO
DEVELOPING A LONGER TERM
APPROACH TO CONNECTING HEARINGS
AND OUR GOAL IS ISSUE THIS NEW
PROCEDURE OVER THE SUMMER.
NOW IF AND WHEN THE TITLE NINE
RULES ARE ISSUED WE WILL AGAIN
NEED TO REVISE AND REASSURE
POLICY MEETING WE WILL HAVE
MULTIPLE VERSIONS OF THE POLICY
IN PLACE IN A RELATIVELY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
WHICH IS CERTAINLY NOT IDEAL AND
SO THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
RIGHT NOW ON COMPOUNDING THAT
THAT YOU SEE WE RECENTLY
UNDERTOOK AN EXTENSIVE PROCESS
TO REVISE OUR SEXUAL VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICY.
AND THAT WAS TO COMPLY WITH AN
IS SIERRA RESOLUTION AGREEMENT
IMPLEMENT RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR AND
MORE SIGNIFICANTLY TO RESPOND TO
EXTENSIVE INPUT THAT WE RECEIVED --
FROM OUR COMMUNITY ON THE POLICY.
WE SUBMITTED THE REVISED POLICY
OCR FOR ITS APPROVAL IN FEBRUARY
WHICH WAS REQUIRED BY THE
RESOLUTION AGREEMENT.
AND WE HAD ANTICIPATED THEY
WOULD APPROVE IT THIS SPRING SO
THAT WE CAN ISSUE IT IN THE
SUMMER.
HOWEVER GIVEN THE TIMELINE RULES
ARE PENDING AND ARE REVISED
POLICY DOES NOT COMPLY WITH
THOSE RULES WE DON'T EXPECT IS
HERE TO APPROVE THAT POLICY --
AT THIS STAGE SO THAT CREATES
ANOTHER LAYER OF UNCERTAINTY AND
SOME OF THESE CHALLENGES I'M
TALKING ABOUT ARE SPECIFIC TO
YOU SEE BUT MANY OF THEM ARE
SHARED BY OTHER UNIVERSITIES AND
SYSTEMS IN THE STATE.
IS A HOPE THIS SHORT
PRESENTATION AND HAS HELPED
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE AND OTHERS ARE FACING
DURING THIS ON CERTAIN TIME.
AS WE WORK HARD TO FULFILL WHAT
IS -- A STRONG AND UNFALTERING
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING A
PROCESS THAT'S NOT ONLY FAIR AND
RESULTING JUSTIN RELIABLE
OUTCOMES BUT THE TREATS PARTIES
WITH RESPECT AND COMPASSION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
KILLER IT WAS WE WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ABILITY OF THE FACT
THAT THEY PROPOSE RULES WOULD BE
REDEFINING SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
UNDER TITLE NINE IN A NARROW
SCOPE -- BUT WOULD NOT NARROW
THE SCOPE OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PROHIBITED BY OTHER LAWS IN
WHICH CASE THE PARALLEL PROCESS
THAT SUZANNE SPOKE WITH ABOUT
EARLIER WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
WE WOULD CERTAINLY WELCOME --
THE PROPOSED RULES ALSO A SEEK
TO ENSURE A FAIR GRIEVANCE
PROCESS IN SCHOOL JUST SIMPLER
AND DISCIPLINARY PROCEEDINGS BY
REQUIRING DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS FOR RESPONDENTS.
HOWEVER THESE -- DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS THAT ARTICULATED IN
THE PROPOSED RULES IN SOME CASES
EXCEED EVEN CRIMINAL.
SAYS PROTECTIONS THAT ARE IN
PLACE -- AND THEREFORE WE FEEL
IS -- AND PRY IMPRACTICAL AND
UNNECESSARY IN TERMS OF AN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION -- WE
ALSO -- COMMENTED TO THE EFFECT
THAT THE CROSS EXAMINATION
REQUIREMENT THAT WOULD ALLOW AN
ADVISER -- CHOSEN BY THE STUDENT
I TO CROSS EXAMINE THE OTHER
PARTY -- WOULD GO AGAINST THE
TRAUMA INFORMED PRACTICES OF
THAT WE'VE.
WE HAVE ATTEMPTED TO IMPLEMENT
THROUGHOUT OUR CAMPUSES -- IN
THIS CASE IT WOULD POTENTIALLY
ALLOW FOR AN ATTORNEY WHO WAS
HIRED BY ONE PARTY -- TO CROSS
EXAMINE ANOTHER STUDENTS AND
KEEP IN MIND THE STUDENTS ARE
AVERAGING ANYWHERE FROM EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD -- AND
WOULD REALLY CREATE THE SORT OF
BECAUSE I JUDICIAL A SITUATION --
THE PROPOSED RULE ALSO EXCLUDES
PRIOR STATEMENTS BY PARTIES THAT
WERE NOT PRESENT AT THE HEARING
SO IN -- IT THEIR INVESTIGATION
PROCESS IF IT WERE DETERMINED
THAT THERE WAS A PARTY A WITNESS
TO THE EVENTS WHO HAD
SIGNIFICANT INFORMATION AND THAT
WITNESS WAS NOT AVAILABLE FOR
THE HEARING THE PROPOSED RULES
WOULD.
AUTOMATICALLY EXCLUDE THE
ABILITY FOR THE HEARING OFFICER
TO CONSIDER THE TESTIMONY OF
THAT INDIVIDUAL.
SO THAT IS ALSO AND AN ERROR AND
WITHOUT ANY HEARSAY EXCEPTIONS --
THAT ARE NORMALLY A PARENT IN IN
CIVIL AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROCEEDINGS -- SO EVEN EVEN THE
MOST FORMAL JUDICIAL PROCESSES
ALLOW FOR THIS IN SOME INSTANCES
AND SO OUR COMMENT SPECIFICALLY
ARTICULATED THE DESIRE FOR THIS
NOT TO BE INCLUDED.
IN THE ULTIMATE RESOLUTION
REGULATIONS -- WITH REGARDS TO
THE RECENT COURT OF APPEALS
DECISION -- WE HAVE ALSO TAKEN
EXTRAORDINARY STEPS TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE.
ONCE THE DECISION WAS ISSUED AND
ON JANUARY FOURTH -- WE ACTED
FAIRLY SWIFTLY ESPECIALLY FOR A
SYSTEM AS LARGE AS OURS AND
ISSUED IMMEDIATE GUIDANCE TO OUR
CAMPUSES TO HALT ALL PROCESSES
ON SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
PENDING MATTERS -- AT THAT POINT --
WE BEGAN IMMEDIATELY WORKING ON
AN INTERIM POLICY SO THAT WE CAN
BECOME COMPLIANT WITH THE
HEARING REQUIREMENTS -- THAT
WERE -- MANDATED AND REQUIRED BY
THIS NEW DECISION -- AS A RESULT --
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON ALSO
TRAINING HEARING OFFICERS -- TO
BEGIN HEARINGS AND WE'RE HOPING
THAT THESE WILL BEGIN IN MID TO
LATE APRIL -- THE INTERIM POLICY
IS ESSENTIALLY BEEN FINALIZED
AND SHOULD BE IN PLACE WERE ANY
MINUTE NOW HONEY TAKE NOW
POSSIBLY -- SOME OF THE KEY
COMPONENTS THAT WE'VE TRIED TO
KEEP IN PLACE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE STILL -- BEING
TREATED FAIRLY AND APPROPRIATELY --
IS THAT STUDENTS WILL BE ALLOWED
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
VIA VIDEO CONFERENCING.
AND THAT STUDENTS -- WILL NOT
ENGAGE IN DIRECT CROSS
EXAMINATION WILL GIVE THEM ON
THE ABILITY FOR THE HEARING
OFFICER SO STUDENTS CAN SUBMIT
THEIR QUESTIONS TO THE HEARING
OFFICER.
WHO WILL THEN -- ADDRESS THOSE
QUESTIONS TO THE PARTIES AS
NECESSARY -- WITH REGARD TO
ATHLETIC FACILITIES WE DO HAVE A
CAMPUS WIDE OUR SYSTEM WIDE
POLICY THAT REQUIRES THAT DEPUTY
TILE NINE COORDINATORS BE
IDENTIFIED.
WHO CAN INSURE THAT THERE IS
FAIRNESS WITHIN OUR ATHLETIC
PROGRAMS -- I WON'T I SEE THAT
MY TIME IS COMING TO A CLOSE SO
I'LL I WILL I WILL SPARE YOU THE
THAT THE LINK THE ADMONITION
WITHIN OUR EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT
MANDATES.
THE AREAS IN WHICH OUR DEPUTY
TIELINE COORDINATORS -- ARE
REQUIRED TO ENSURE FAIRNESS AND
OUR ATHLETIC PROGRAMS BUT IT IS
A NOT FOR OUR POLICIES AND AND
COMPLIED WITH REGULARLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MISS
WHOSE HOME WILL GO TO A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
PETER CONN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
PETER CAM A DEPUTY COUNSEL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES -- IN MY ROLE I DO
PRODUCT PROVIDED ADVICE ADVICE
GUIDANCE ON TITLE NINE CLEARY
ACT -- TRANSGENDER STUDENTS
RIGHTS AND ALSO TITLE FIVE THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNE COLLEGE THEY
PROMULGATE REGULATIONS AND WE DO
HAVE A TITLE.
FIVE PROCESS THAT -- PREVENTS --
PROHIBITS DISCRIMINATION ON
PROTECTED CLASSES AND
CHARACTERISTICS SEX AND GENDER --
THEY ARE INCLUDED AND SO.
WE HAVE SEVENTY THREE LOCALLY
ELECTED BOARDS AND WIN THE TITLE
NINE PROPOSED REGULATIONS OR
WERE RELEASED WE DID OUR
CHANCELLOR DID -- SUBMIT
COMMENTS VERY SIMILAR CONCERNS
THE UC AND CSU -- I THINK OUR
BIGGEST CONCERN WAS THE
SIGNIFICANT CHILLING EFFECT ON
THE VICTIM'S ABILITY AND THE
WILLINGNESS TO COME FORWARD TO
REPORT SEXUAL HARASSMENT SEXUAL
ASSAULT -- SPECIFICALLY THE
PROCEDURAL BEARS THAT THE
PROPOSED REGULATIONS --
DISCUSSED THE STANDARD OF
EVIDENCE AND ALSO THE CROSS
EXAMINATION THAT HAS BEEN
PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED --
FURTHERMORE THE DEFINITIONS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ACTUAL
KNOWLEDGE WE BELIEVE ARE TOO
NARROW -- IT ENABLES
INSTITUTIONS TO TURN A BLIND EYE
A DISABLED WE DIDN'T HAVE ACTUAL
KNOWLEDGE.
AND THE DELIBERATE INDIFFERENCE
STANDARD THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER IS
TOO HIGH OF A STANDARD -- WE DO
HAVE STUDENTS TO STUDY ABROAD AS
WELL SO TITLE AND THE PROPOSED
HAD AND I REGULATIONS -- WOULD
NOT ALLOW STUDENTS TO STUDY
ABROAD AND HAVE ANOTHER STUDENT --
HYPOTHETICALLY -- AND SEXUALLY
HARASSED SECTION SAW AND WHEN
THOSE STUDENTS COME BACK THERE
WOULD BE NO PROTECTION FOR THAT
STUDENTS SO WE WE DID DISCUSS
THAT AS WELL.
AND YOU KNOW OUR OUR COMMENTS
WERE TEN PAGES IN THERE ALSO IN
INCLUDED IN YOUR MATERIALS TODAY.
IN RESPONSE TO THE TITLE NINE
NUMBER TEN NINE REGULATIONS WE
HAVE SENT ADVISORIES TO OUR
COLLEGES AND WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF UPDATING OUR TITLE
FIVE REGULATIONS -- SPECIFICALLY
WE WANT.
TO I'M GOING TO DISCUSS AND WE
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THERE IS
A EDUCATION CODE SECTION THAT --
ANY TYPE OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE STALKING THE
PREPONDERANCE OF THE EVIDENCE
STANDARD WOULD BE APPLIED.
AND IN LIGHT OF THE U. S. C.
CASE.
ANY TYPE OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT --
WHERE AS A STUDENT IS --
SEVERELY DISCIPLINED THE YOU
KNOW THE THE IN DIRECT.
AND INDIRECT HEARING WE WE ARE
GOING TO BE DISCUSSING THAT AS
WELL -- WE'RE DOING SOMETHING
SIMILAR TO A CSU IS DOING WHERE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ALLOW FOR A
DIRECT -- EXAMINATION SO THE THE
CALVARY COMMUNICABLE AGES WE
WERE THE LARGEST POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTION IN THE UNITED STATES
WE SERVE TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND SO WE
FEEL AS IF YOU WE DO HAVE A NEED
TO PROTECT OUR STUDENTS WE ALSO
HAVE CLASSIFIED STAFF MEMBERS
YET THOUSANDS OF CLASS BY STAFF
MEMBERS.
AND FACULTY MEMBERS THAT SERVE
OUR STUDENTS SO -- WE UNDERSTAND
THAT.
NOT ONLY ARE WE SERVING OUR
STUDENTS BUT ALSO ARE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE -- HELPING
THE IN EDUCATE OUR STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CAN ON NOW WE
MOVE TO THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT COLIFORM.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON --
CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU
TODAY -- MY NAME IS THOMAS OF
WHO I AM WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES.
A I SEE SEE YOU AS THE U. --
ORGANIZATIONAL VOICE FOR OVER
EIGHTY INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS IN
THE STATE -- TOGETHER THE ICC
MEBER INSTITUTIONS EDUCATE
NEARLY WHILE ONE HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS
AND OVER ONE HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
THOUSAND GRADUATE STUDENTS.
OUR MEMBER INSTITUTIONS ARE
DIVERSE IN MANY REGARDS -- IN
MISSION IS TO EMBODY AND AND
RESOURCES WHAT IS COMMON AMONG
THEM.
IS THAT ALL OF OUR MEMBER
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES ARE
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS FOR THEIR STUDENTS.
IT'S COMMITMENT INCLUDES WORKING
WITH STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF
TO DEVELOP POLICIES PRACTICES
AND SOLUTIONS.
THEY DO SO IN THE FRAMEWORK OF
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AND LEGAL
INTERPRETATIONS BY COURTS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY -- AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS INSTITUTIONS JUST
WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS --
INDEPENDENT INSTITUTIONS HAVE
ADAPTED TO FEDERAL GUIDANCE AND
STATE LAWS AROUND TITLE NINE AND
CAMPUS SEXUAL ASSAULT.
INSTITUTIONS OF ESTABLISH THE
POLICIES IN PROCESS SEASON TRAIN
THEIR STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF.
OUR PRESIDENT SHARE THE SAME
CONCERNS -- AS OUR PARTNERS IN
THE PUBLIC SECTOR -- ABOUT THE
US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
NOTICE OF PROPOSED RULEMAKING OR
NPR M. -- THAT WOULD AMEND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF TITLE.
NINE AND THE EFFECTS WOULD HAVE
ON STUDENTS AND INSTITUTIONAL
EFFORTS TO COMBAT.
A CAMPUS SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
MISCONDUCT.
IN JANUARY -- AICC YOU JOINED A
LETTER BY THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
ON EDUCATION.
ADDRESS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ABOUT THE NPR M. WHICH
I'VE.
THEIR SERGEANTS HAVE ABOUT
PASSED OUT -- AND THE COMMENTS
EXPRESSED OUR STRONG CONCERNS
ABOUT PROVISIONS IN THE PROPOSED
REGULATIONS THAT WE BELIEVE
WOULD UNDERMINE INSTITUTIONS
ABILITIES -- TO ENSURE EQUITABLE
AND FAIR RESOLUTIONS AND TO
PROTECT VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND MISCONDUCT.
I JUST WANT TO ADDRESS QUICKLY
DRESSED OF A COUPLE OF A VERY
PROBLEMATIC POINTS ABOUT -- THAT
WE SHARE ABOUT THE A PROPOSED
REGULATIONS.
THAT THEY WOULD REQUIRE A LOT
HEARINGS AS AS BEEN MENTIONED
AND CROSS EXAMINATIONS AND
ALLOWS THE AFFECTED STUDENTS TO
HIRE ADVISERS TO ASSIST AND THE
QUESTIONING.
IF THE RESPONDENT OR ACCUSER
CANNOT AFFORD AN ADVISER THE
CAMPUS MUST HIRE ONE FOR THE
STUDENT.
OUR CAMPUSES RESOURCES ARE VERY
DIVERSE.
AND FOR SOME SMALLER
INSTITUTIONS COULD BE THIS COULD
BE A VERY COSTLY -- TO IMPLEMENT.
THIS PROCESS EFFECTIVELY TURNS
OUR CAMPUSES INTO BECAUSE I
COURTROOMS WE BELIEVE THIS WILL
HAVE A CHILLING EFFECTS ON THE
REPORTING OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
AND THE WILLINGNESS OF VICTIMS
WITNESSES AND RESPOND AS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS.
THIS PROCESS TO INVESTIGATE
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
IS NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
STUDENTS.
THE PUBLICATION THAT
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES AIMS
TO PROTECT INSTEAD INSTITUTIONS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN THE
ABILITY TO CHOOSE HOW THEY
INVESTIGATE CLAIMS INCLUDING
ALLOWING QUESTIONING THROUGH A
PANEL OR SUBMISSION OF QUESTIONS.
THE PROPOSED RULES ALSO REQUIRE
A SINGLE FEDERALLY MANDATED
EVIDENTIARY STANDARD OF PROOF.
ACROSS ALL DISCIPLINARY PROCESS
THESE.
NPR AND ALLOWS INSTITUTIONS TO
SELECT OTHER PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE OR CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE THAT STANDARD OF PROOF.
BUT THEY MUST ALSO APPLIED THE
SELECTION ACROSS THE BOARD THIS
MEANS THAT THE SAME CENTER OF
PROOF MUST BE ADOPTED FOR ALL
PROCEEDINGS WHETHER IT'S SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT -- EMPLOYEE
DISCIPLINE PLAGIARISM VIOLATIONS
AT CETERA.
WE BELIEVE THIS ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH IS WRONG WE BELIEVE
THE IS THAT INSTITUTIONS SHOULD
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO CHOOSE
DEPENDING ON THE VIOLATION.
AND THAT THE DEPARTMENT SHOULD
NOT MICROMANAGE CAMPUS
DISCIPLINARY PROCEEDINGS.
IN REGARDS TO THE CALIFORNIA
COURT OF APPEALS RECENT DECISION --
LIKE THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF ED.
THE COURT DECISION UP AND OUR
INSTITUTIONS ESTABLISHED PROCESS
THESE -- THE DECISION SIMILAR TO
WHAT THE NPR IN PROPOSES TO DO
TAKES AWAY UNIVERSITIES ABILITY
TO CHOOSE HOW THEY INVESTIGATE
INVESTIGATE CLAIMS.
AND HOW THEY CONDUCT QUESTIONING.
OUR MEMBER INSTITUTIONS ARE
ASSESSING THE COURT DECISION TO
UNDERSTAND -- THE IMPACT ON
STUDENTS AND THEIR INVESTIGATORY
PROCESS SEES AND HOW THEY WOULD
NEED TO CHANGE THEIR PRACTICES
TO BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
DECISION.
HOW FINISHED BY SAYING THAT AND
MISS THE CHANGING LANDSCAPE ON
THE FEDERAL AND STATE LEVELS ARE
MEMBER CAMPUSES REMAIN COMMITTED
TO UPHOLDING CIVIL RIGHTS?
AND TO CREATING CAMPUS
ENVIRONMENTS THAT ARE SAFE AND
SUPPORTIVE AND RESPONSIVE TO ALL
STUDENTS.
AND AS BOTH LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENTS ARE DECIDING HOW TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE OUR UNIVERSITIES ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
CONFLICT BETWEEN FEDERAL LAWS
AND STATE LAWS.
AND THERE IS STUDENTS BEING
CAUGHT IN BETWEEN.
I THANK YOU AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FROM.
SURE MEDINA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION -- AS CHAIR OF
HIGHER ED -- YOU YOU'RE SHOULD
PRIVACY PRETTY AWARE OF THE
HEARINGS THAT WE'VE HAD OVER THE
YEARS AT THE DIFFERENT --
ESPECIALLY UC CAMPUSES WERE.
OF MY PREDECESSOR DAS WILLIAMS --
CONVENE UP AND DOWN THE STATE AT
UC SANTA BARBARA AND UCLA --
WHERE WE HEARD?
OF FROM STUDENT -- VICTIMS.
RIGHT -- AND SO AT THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN VERY IMPORTANT A TWO TO OUR
COMMITTEE -- BUT AT THE SAME
TIME -- I THINK -- I I WAS AWARE
AND AND I AND I WOULD THINK THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
DIFFERENT -- INSTITUTIONS WERE
PROBABLY AWARE THAT THE COURTS --
MIGHT NOT HAVE -- YOU KNOW EVEN
AS WE WERE HAVING THOSE HEARINGS
WE WERE HEARING THAT THE COURTS
MIGHT NOT UPHOLD.
A STRICT NOUS OF OUR RULES AS AS
THEY PERTAIN TO THE PERPETRATORS
AND TO THE PROCESSES.
AND AND THE CONSEQUENCES.
AND SO HOW SURPRISE ARE WE FROM
THE COURT OF APPEALS DECISION.
I AND I AND CHANGING.
THE WAY -- WE HAVE.
TO CONDUCT BUSINESS IF YOU WILL.
ARE WE SURPRISE -- I DON'T I'M
NOT QUITE SURE HOW TO ANSWER
THAT AND I DON'T KNOW IF.
I WOULD SAY THAT THEY WERE
SUPPOSED [inaudible]
SURPRISED -- BUT IT DOES CREATE --
IS THE SOME CONSTERNATION AND
YOU KNOW GOING BACK TO AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED NO LOOKING AT
THEIR PROCESS SEES AND KNOWS
SPECIALLY GIVEN.
HOW DIVERSE OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE
SOME HAVE MORE RESOURCE
RESOURCES AND OTHERS -- IT
CREATES A CHALLENGE -- FOR MANY
OF OUR INSTITUTIONS AND AND
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE NOW WITH
THE COURT OF APPEALS CHANGING
THE WAY.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS TO
DO THE PROCESS OF OF CARRYING
OUT THE NOT SO MUCH THE
INVESTIGATION BUT THE ACTUAL --
WAY IT COMES TO A CONCLUSION
RIGHT WERE GIVEN THE GIVEN THE
ALLEGED PERPETRATOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO ADDRESS -- THE THE VICTIM
CORRECT THAT THAT'S A CHANGE IS
THAT RIGHT.
RIGHT SO FOR MANY YEARS THE
SINGLE INVESTIGATOR MODEL HAD
BEEN A MODEL THAT WAS I'M
CONSIDERED APPROPRIATE IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND WHAT THAT
MODEL MEN'S WAS THAT.
THERE WOULD BE ONE INVESTIGATOR
WHO WOULD CONDUCT THE
INVESTIGATION -- MAKE FINDINGS
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
GOING TO POLICY VIOLATION AND
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
SANCTIONS -- WHAT THE COURTS
HAVE NOW REQUIRED IS THAT THERE
IS A HEARING PROCESS THAT IS
ALLOWS FOR A SEPARATE HEARING
OFFICER? TO REVIEW THE
INVESTIGATORY -- REPORT OF THE
INVESTIGATOR AND THEN MAKE THE
FINDINGS -- FROM THEIR SEPARATE
SPHERE -- THEIR SEPARATE
PERSPECTIVE -- IS SO SORRY JUST
TO SPEAK TO YOUR EARLIER
QUESTION.
EITHER WAS -- SOME INDICATION
THAT THE COURTS WERE MOVING IN
THIS DIRECTION IT WAS NOT A
COMPLETE AND TOTAL SURPRISE.
HOWEVER HAVING SAID THAT I THINK
IT'S BEEN MADE CLEAR MANY TIMES
BEFORE AND EVEN THE COURT OF
APPEALS HAVE SAT IN PRIOR
RULINGS.
THAT THESE OUR CLASSROOMS AND
NOT COURT ROOMS SO THE DEGREE TO
WHICH THE COURT HAS SEEN TO IT --
TRANSPOSON TO AN EDGE WHAT HAS
NORMALLY BEEN AN EDUCATIONAL
PROCESS I THINK IT'S CAUGHT SOME
OF US BY SURPRISE.
HEY AND JUST SO FOR MY OWN
CLARIFICATION.
AMONG THE CHANGES THAT THE COURT
SAID IS THAT THE ALLEGE PEPPERED
PERPETRATOR HAS THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO TO QUESTION IS THAT THAT'S A
NEW.
ABILITY TO QUESTION IS SOMETHING
THAT WAS ALREADY WELL
ESTABLISHED AND IS ONE TO
EXPLAIN THAT SOMETHING THAT WAS
PROVIDED THROUGH.
ON EITHER HEARING OR THE SINGLE
INVESTIGATOR MODEL THAT MANY
INSTITUTIONS USE IT'S THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THERE BE A LIVE
HEARING.
ON IN CERTAIN SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
CASES THAT IS NEW [inaudible]
ALIVE.
OKAY AND AND THIS COURT HEARING
WHAT WOULD WHAT EFFECT DO YOU
THINK OF IT WILL HAVE ON THE
REPORTING.
OF SEXUAL ASSAULTS.
IN IN THE DIFFERENT SYSTEMS.
WE START RIGHT OKAY.
WHERE WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CHILLING EFFECT IT MAY HAVE ON
REPORTING -- THAT THE THE THE
IDEA OF HAVING THE IDEA BEHIND
THE SINGLE INVESTIGATOR MODEL
WAS THAT A LITTLE WHILE IT WOULD
ALLOW FOR QUESTIONING TO OCCUR
BETWEEN THE PARTIES WOULD BE
DONE THROUGH THE INTERMEDIARY
INVESTIGATOR.
THIS NEW MODEL ALTHOUGH WE ARE
ALLOWING PARTIES TO BE IN
SEPARATE LOCATIONS WHERE HAVING
THE QUESTIONS COME THROUGH THE
HEARING OFFICER.
IN OUR EFFORT TO SORT OF MEET TO
MAINTAIN AS MUCH -- INTEGRITY OF
THE NORTH -- PRIOR PROCESS THAT
WE CAN -- WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACT TO COMPLAINTS OF
HAVING.
TO SIT IN A ROOM POTENTIALLY
EVEN IF IT'S VIRTUALLY -- WITH
THE PERSON THEY'RE ACCUSING OF
HAVING SEXUALLY ASSAULTED THEM.
HAVE WE SEEN THE NUMBER GO DOWN
ALREADY OR NOT YET WE WE ARE
EARLY TO TELL I THINK IT'S TOO
EARLY TO TELL YEAH I THINK IT'S
REALLY TELLING AND ONE THING I
WOULD ADD ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
AT THE THE US YOU CASE --
ANYTIME IS A STUDENT IS ACCUSED
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AND THE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION ON THE
STUDENT IS VERY SEVERE.
AND THE WITNESS IN A WIN THIS IS
THE CREDIBILITY IS AT ISSUE
THAT'S WHEN -- THE LIVE HEARING --
THAT THAT'S WHEN THE COURT RULED
THAT THERE SHOULD BE A LIVE
HEARING AND AND ONE THING I
WOULD ALSO POINT OUT IS THAT THE
COURT OF APPEALS ARE DOWN NELLIE
WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM A COURT OF
APPEAL IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IN THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
HAS HAS ALSO NOT RULED -- ON
THIS ISSUE.
AND MAYBE YOU LAST QUESTION.
IF I MAY THE GOVERNOR RECENTLY
IN NOVEMBER -- ISSUED A REPORT
ON SEXUAL MISCONDUCT ISSUES ANY
THOUGHTS ON HIS REPORT IF YOU
HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK AT THE
GOVERNOR'S.
REPORT ON SEXUAL MISCONDUCT OF
NOVEMBER.
WELL AT AS I SAID AND YOU SEE IS
WELL WE HAVE THIS AND TERM
PROCESS IN PLACE DEVELOPING A
LONGER TERM MODEL AND WE FOUND
THAT REPORT TO BE VERY
INSTRUCTIVE AND HELPFUL.
IN WORKING THROUGH THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THINK YOU'LL A PANELIST WHO
ARE MOVING ON TO THE LAST
[inaudible]
BUT DEFINITELY NOT THE LEAST.
WE HAVE A PANEL OF CATERED TO K..
TO TWELVE EDUCATION LEADERS.
WHO SHARE WITH US -- DEAR RUTH --
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THIS
CHALLENGES.
BUT OPPOSED BY ENFORCING THE
TITLE.
NINE AND WITH US TODAY THE WE
HAVE.
HE NAMED JACKSON.
AN INJECTION OF THE DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
ROGER BLAKE.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA --
INTEREST COLOR.
FEDERATION AND ASHLEY.
MISSOURI MORE TOLL THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF STRANGERS CALL THE
STATE.
ATHLETIC CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR HEALTH PHYSICAL EDUCATION
RECREATION AND DANCE.
YEAH AND ALSO [inaudible]
KIM TURNER.
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY.
FAIR PLAY FOR GIRLS IN SPORTS
PROJECT.
ALL RIGHT AT THE TABLE THANK YOU.
I LIKE IT OKAY.
WE'LL START WITH THE THIS
PROJECTION [inaudible]
YOUR ALL.
RIGHT.
AFTERNOON SIR COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KIND JACKSON DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT GOVERNMENT FAIRS
AND CHARTER SCHOOLS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION.
TONY THURMOND SO THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE.
TODAY.
SURE YOU CAN.
I DO THIS I'LL TRY TO MAKE SURE
I WORK THE POWER POINT CORRECTLY.
SO YOU DON'T CALIFORNIA HAS A
PROUD HISTORY OF GOING ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
IN MANY AREAS AND GENDER
EQUALITY IS ONE OF THEM.
TITLE NINE IS APPLICABLES TO
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS
DISTRICTS COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
THAT RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDS.
EACH SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT
RECEIVES FEDERAL FUNDS IS
REQUIRED TO HAVE A TITLE NINE
COORDINATOR THAT IS VISIBLE AND
IT IS AN INTEGRAL PART OF
ENSURING NONDISCRIMINATION AT
SCHOOLS. ONE WAY CALIFORNIA GOES
ABOVE AND BEYOND IS THAT IT
PROHIBITS DISCRIMINATION BASED
ON GENDER.
GENDER EXPRESSION GENDER
IDENTITY AND SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AS YOU AS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY.
ANOTHER IS THROUGH SENATE BILL
ONE THREE SEVEN FIVE OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
STRENGTHENED AND EXPANDED.
COM.
THE TITLE NINE AND STATE SEX
EQUITY IN EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS IT REQUIRES A
PUBLIC SCHOOLS PRIVATE SCHOOLS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
AND CHARTER SCHOOLS PULLS
INFORMATION ON THEIR INTERNET
WEBSITE RELATIVE TO THE
DESIGNATED TITLE NINE
COORDINATOR.
THE RIGHTS OF STUDENTS IN THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF SCHOOLS AND
A DESCRIPTION OF HOW TO FILE A
COMPLAINT.
WITH RESPECT TO ENSURING EQUITY.
THERE ARE THREE TYPES OF
MONITORING IMPLYING OF
COMPLIANCE ACTIVITIES THAT OCCUR
ONE EDUCATIONAL EQUITY REVIEWS
AND EXAMPLES OF REVIEWS ARE
ENSURING THAT DISTRICTS HAVE A
PROCESS TO IDENTIFY AND RESOLVE.
DISPROPORTIONAL NUMBER OF
STUDENTS OF ONE SEX IN A
PARTICULAR COURSE FOR EXAMPLE
ENSURING THAT IT LET IT PROGRAM
SUPPORTED BY PUBLIC FUNDS
PROVIDE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY. FOR
PARTICIPATION BY ALL STUDENTS
AND ENSURING EQUITABLE USE OF
SUCH FUNDS.
ALL STUDENT CLUBS HAVE ACCESS TO
FACILITIES AND A FAIR
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET.
COURSES IN ACTIVITIES DO NOT
RESULT IN THE SEPARATION OF
STUDENTS BASED ON PROTECTED
FACTORS SUCH AS GENDER ETHNICITY.
AND COUNSELING MATERIALS ARE
FREE FROM DISCRIMINATION BASED
ON SEX. TO CIVIL RIGHTS IN
FEDERAL REVIEWS THESE REVIEWS
HAVE FOCUSED ON ALL FEDERAL
CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS WHICH INCLUDES
TITLE NINE AND ALSO GENDER
EQUITY IN THE RECRUITMENT.
AND IT ADMISSIONS TO CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
AND ALSO ITEMS SUCH AS ENSURING
THAT LOCKER ROOMS CHANGING ROOMS
ROOMS SHOWERS RESTROOMS NEW THE
C. T. E. AREAS ARE COMPATIBLE
FOR BOTH MEN AND WOMEN WITH THE
SAME AMENITIES AND APPROXIMATE
SPACE.
AND LASTLY UNIFORM COMPLAINT
PROCEDURES THE UC P. AS YOU KNOW
IS A CALIFORNIA'S COMPLAINT
PROCESS FOR ISSUES RELATED TO
THE DISCRIMINATION HARASSMENT
INTIMIDATION OR BULLYING.
IT IS WHERE STUDENTS PARENTS AND
OTHERS MAY FILE COMPLAINTS
RELATED TO TITLE NINE AND OTHER
ISSUES.
OKAY SO NOW THAT I BRIEFLY JUST
DISCUSS FOR YOU SOME OF OUR MORE
FORMAL PROCESSES REGARDING
MONITORING AND EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY I REALLY AM EXCITED TO
HIGHLIGHT OUR RESOURCES
PERTAINING TO GENDER EQUITY.
IN THIS CASE A SPECIFIC AROUND
STEM EDUCATION THAT ARE DRESSING
IN EQUITY FOR GIRLS AND SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING AND MATH.
SO AS WE KNOW WOMEN IN THE
WORKFORCE AND IN THIS NATION ARE
ARE REALLY UNDER UTILIZE
UNTAPPED GREATEST FORCE THAT WE
HAVE.
THE UNDER REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN IN STEM RELATED JOBS
PLACES THEM AT AN ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE WOMEN IN STEM JOBS
EARN ON AVERAGE 33% MORE THAN
THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN NON STAM
RELATED JOBS.
FROM AN EARLY AGE -- FROM AS
EARLY IN AGES FOUR YEARS OLD
PERCEPTIONS ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATE GENDER OF SCIENTISTS
AND ENGINEERS IS INFLUENCE AND
REINFORCED BY THE MEDIA.
PREDOMINATE IMAGES OF MEN AND IN
STEM RELATED FIELDS IN THE MEDIA
CALLS BOTH GIRLS AND YOUNG WOMEN
BOYS AND YOUNG MEN TO SEE THESE
FEELS AS MORE MALE DOMINATED.
AND MORE MASCULINE IN NATURE.
SO ARE THE CALIFORNIA FRAMEWORK.
ALL TEACHERS AND EDUCATION
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS CAN ENSURE
THAT CREATING A LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT THAT PROMOTES OPEN
DIALOGUE RISK TAKING AND A
CULTURE THAT VALUES LEARNING
WERE ALL STUDENTS FEEL SAFE.
AND EXCITED ABOUT ENGAGING WITH
SCIENCE AND ENGINEERING ALL
TEACHERS CAN SUPPORT GIRLS AND
YOUNG WOMEN TO THRIVE AND STAND
CLASSROOMS.
NO ONE THING THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW IS -- YEAH MYSELF AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT IS SELF OR
RAISING YOUNG GIRLS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO US THAT WE FOSTER
POSITIVE DIALOGUE AROUND THIS
CONVERSATION.
AND SO ON YOU CAN SEE THAT ARE
FRAMEWORK GUIDES TEACHERS TO
PLACE GIRLS IN LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS DURING GROUP WORK CAN
BE A POSITIVE IMAGES REGARDING
THE COMPETENCY OF GIRLS.
HIGHLIGHT WOMEN ROLLS AND
MENTORS IN STEM FIELDS ASSESS
THEMSELVES IN.
ENSURING FEMALE STUDENTS HAVE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE.
H. BRINGS US TO EXPANDING
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR GIRLS
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION STEM OFFICE
PARTNERED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS TO ACTIVELY
ENGAGE STUDENTS. TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION FOR WOMEN IN STEM
FIELDS THIS RESULTED IN THREE
SEPARATE -- ENGAGING GIRLS IN
STEM TOWN HALL EVENTS THESE
EVENTS HAVE BEEN CONTINUING IN
AN ONGOING BASIS AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL AROUND THE STATE.
AND FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE MERCED COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION HAS BEGUN A
PROGRAM THAT SINCE FEMALE
STUDENTS AND THEIR MOTHERS
GRANDMOTHERS AND OTHER FEMALE
GUARDIANS TO SCIENCE CAMP
TOGETHER.
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT GIRLS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO ENGAGE IN STEM
FIELDS IF THEY DO SO WITH ROLE
MODELS THAT THEY HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT PERSONAL CONNECTION
WITH?
AND THIS WAS THE IDEA BEHIND
STUDENTS ENGAGING WITH STAMINA
OTHER FEMALE MEMBERS OF THEIR
FAMILY.
WITH OTHER MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY.
AND THIS IS JUST A PICTURE JUST
SHOWING SOME OF THE PARTICIPANTS
OF ONE OF THE THREE COUNTY
ENGAGING GIRLS AND STAND TOWN
HALLS.
AND SO WITH THIS POSITIVE NOTE --
ANY QUESTIONS THAT'S ALL I HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- NEXT WILL
WORK -- BUT ROGER HELP ME OUT
HERE YEAH.
AND WE JUST GOT TO FIND IT IS.
TELL ME THAT'S IT I THINK THAT'S
HEY VALUE.
THANK YOU I'M GLAD TO BE HERE
I'M ROGER BLAKE OF THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
PLASTIC FEDERATION WITH THE
GOVERNING BODY HIGH SCHOOL
SPORTS FOR CALIFORNIA.
I AM HAPPY TO TELL YOU I AFTER
FORTY THREE YEARS IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION PUBLIC SERVICE I'M
RETIRED AT THE END OF THIS YEAR
SO I HAVE BROUGHT MY STAFF ALONG
BECAUSE SOMEONE ELSE HAS TO
CARRY THIS ON AND THIS IS A
IMPORTANT TOPIC.
SO I HAVE A STAFF HERE ALONG
WITH THE AND DIANNE MARSHALL
FREEMAN OR GENERAL COUNSEL SHE
WAS.
CAUGHT UNFORTUNATELY HE'S OUR
GENERAL COUNSEL SHE'S DEALING
WITH AN ISSUE FOR US RIGHT NOW
SO SHE WASN'T ABLE TO JOIN US.
THIS IS THE WORD I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT TALK ABOUT TODAY'S THE
ATHLETIC AREAS.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE FUN.
SO THIS IS HOW WE ALL LOOK ON
MONDAY.
AND THAT'S ALWAYS A BY FRIDAY.
AND I AND I RUN INTO MANY OF
YOUR THE LEGISLATORS WHEN YOU'RE
GOING HOME TO YOUR DISTRICTS ON
THURSDAY AFTERNOON THE AIRPORT
WHEN I'M GONE SOMEWHERE AND I
THINK WE ALL CAN RELATE TO THAT
SO -- CAN HAVE SOME FUN WITH
THIS OKAY HERE WE GO CHAU.
YOU CAN SEE WE HAVE A SIXTEEN
HUNDRED AT JUST OVER SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HIGH SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA. ONE POINT NINE
MILLION -- HIGH SCHOOL AGE
STUDENTS BUT ABOUT SIX POINT TWO
MILLION K. TWELVE STUDENTS SO
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING AND YOU
HEARD ALL THE THINGS TODAY ABOUT
TITLE NINE YOU GOT TO THINK A
LITTLE BIGGER THAN.
MY WORLD IS ONE POINT.
NINE BUT HIS IS SIX POINT WO
AND SO IT'S IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THIS IS THE NUMBERS THAT
I WANT TO SHARE.
I'VE BEEN WITH TWENTY ONE YEARS
NOW WITH THE C. I. F. A. N. AS
YOU CAN SEE PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE.
IF YOU LOOK IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR NUMBER OF KIDS OR
PARTICIPATE IN HIGH SCHOOL
SPORTS.
COMPARED TO TODAY AND ON END
WHAT'S REALLY GOOD ABOUT THOSE
NUMBERS OF TOTAL PARTICIPANTS.
HIGH SCHOOL ENROLLMENT IS
ACTUALLY GONE DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
SO WHAT'S GOOD IS BORN MORE BOYS
AND GIRLS ARE PARTICIPATING IN
ATHLETICS THAT SOIT SHOWS YOU
THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE OFFERING
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR KIDS.
YOUR FEEL THE DRAINS ALSO OF IF
YOU BUILD IT DOT COM WELL.
DONE -- LET'S BUILD IT KIDS ARE
KIDS.
BUT YOU CAN SEE THE NUMBER
THOUGH WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF MALE AND FEMALE
STUDENTS LOOK AT THE GENDER GAP
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR TO TODAY
IT'S CLOSED.
BUT THAT STILL SIGNIFICANT GAP.
IN ONE OF THE THINGS PEOPLE SEEM
TO FORGET AND THAT'S WHY I WAS
KIND OF HIGHLIGHTED HERE AT THE
BOTTOM SHE DOES IT BECAUSE SHE
SMILES.
SHE'S RIGHT THERE SHE'S AT THE
SCHOOL SITE THESE DAYS.
KIDS PLAY BECAUSE IT'S FUN.
MEET ALL THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE IT
ON MY WORLD OF ATHLETICS IS
ISN'T THE KIDS THE KIDS ARE OKAY.
BUT IS THE ADULTS IN US OFFERING
OPPORTUNITIES.
SO THERE'S THE NUMBERS IN HERE
IS ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT I
THINK OUR SCHOOLS FACE TODAY IS
THAT LITTLE RED ERROL AT THE
BOTTOM.
WHEN I'M SIXTY FIVE I'M A LITTLE
OLD I'M RETIRED?
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL ALL OF
MY COACHES WERE TEACHERS AT
SCHOOL THAT'S NOT THE CASE
ANYMORE 72% OF THE TEACHERS
COACHES OF OUR HIGH SCHOOL KIDS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE WALKEN'S?
GREAT MEN AND WOMEN THEY COME TO
SCHOOL.
AFTER SCHOOL IS OUT SO THEY
DON'T SEE THEIR KIDS AT ALL
ACCEPTED PRACTICE ONE OF THE
ISSUES I THINK.
IN THIS IS PURELY ANECDOTAL FROM
MY STANDPOINT WHAT THAT'S A BIG
ISSUE BECAUSE THAT TEACHER ON
CAMPUS THAT SEES A GOOD STUDENT
A GOOD KIDS.
IS THAT RECRUITING THEM TO COME
PLAY SPORTS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
INVOLVED OR NOT INVOLVED IN THE
CHESS CLUB THE DRUMMER ANYTHING.
BECAUSE THEY'RE GREAT.
BUT THE VOLUNTEERING THEIR TIME
AFTER SCHOOL SO THAT CREATES A
PROBLEM ON OUR CAMPUSES FOR OUR
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS.
SO HERE EQUITY IN SCHOOLS.
SOME OF THOSE PICTURES I LOVE
SOME OF THEM THAT ONE YOU
PROBABLY RECOGNIZE IN THE BOTTOM
A SWEET WATER. EIGHTY THIS YOU
HEARD ALL THIS STUFF EARLIER
TODAY IT AND IT'S THEIR
IMPORTANT SUBJECTS BUT IT.
IN DEALING WITH THE LAW IN
EVERYTHING IS HAPPENING.
BUT IT'S IT'S SO DIFFICULT I
GUESS I WANT TO MAKE THIS AND IF
YOU JUST INDULGE ME FOR TWO
MINUTES.
THIS IS HOW EASY TITLE NINE IS I
NOW USE THIS EXPLANATION I'D GO
OUT AND DO PRESENTATIONS ALWAYS
WITH ACCESS THE ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENTS.
WITH THEIR SCHOOL BOARDS SO IF
YOU TWO WOULD JUST INDULGE ME
FOR SAYING READY.
THIS IS MY SON AND THIS IS MY
DAUGHTER.
THANK GOD YOU DIDN'T HAVE MY
JEANS ARE YOU WITH A GUN.
THIS IS MY SON AND THIS IS MY
DAUGHTER.
DO I TREATED THE SAME.
NO.
I TREATING DEFINITELY THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT LOVES DIFFERENT NEEDS
DIFFERENT THINGS THEY LOVE TO DO.
HI BUT WE'RE GONNA SUPPORT IN
WITH EVERYTHING WE GOT.
NOW SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
SUPERINTENDENTS UPDATE THINK
ABOUT THIS IS YOUR CHECK YOUR
KIDS HERE THEY ARE.
NO COMES CHRISTMAS TIME.
DO I TAKE MY SON TO NORDSTROM'S
IN MY DAUGHTER TO TARGET.
WELL WE'RE PUBLIC EDUCATORS SO
WHERE HAVE WE'RE LUCKY WE COULD
AFFORD MACY'S.
BUT NO WE WOULDN'T DO THAT WOULD
WE THAT'S WHAT TOTAL LINE SAYS
I'M GONNA TREAT MY SON AND
DAUGHTER THE SAME I'M NOT TAKING
HIM TO NORDSTROM SENT HER. TO
TARGET.
LIKE TREATING THEM THE SAME
WE'RE GONNA GO TO MACY'S AND
WE'RE GONNA GET THE SAME QUALITY
MATERIALS AND AN ATHLETIC
EQUIPMENT.
SO I WANT TO GET INTO THEIR
WORLD IN THAT IN THERE LIKE YOU
START SEEING THEIR HEADS NOT AND
THEN THE NEXT IF YOU GO.
NOW EVERY YEAR CHRISTMAS UNCLE
RON RIGHT THERE IN THE MIDDLE
BLOOM THE CIGAR COMES TO
CHRISTMAS IN EVERY YEAR AT
CHRISTMAS.
HE COMES TO MY SON.
HERE'S YOUR BMX BIKE.
COOL HERE IS MORE -- DON'T KNOW
LET'S LET'S JUST GIVE HER THIS
OKAY AND THEN WHAT DO YOU DO
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT YEAR WHEN
UNCLE RUN COMES TO CHRISTMAS AND
YOU GET A BRAND NEW BASEBALL BAT
TO COST THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND MY DAUGHTER SHE GETS
SOMETHING THAT'S JUST.
LAUGHS WHAT DO I DO AS A DAD.
I TELL.
UNCLE RON YOU CAN'T COME TO
CHRISTMAS ANYMORE.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DO THIS TO
MY KIDS.
IN THE WORLD OF HIGH SCHOOL
SPORTS WHO IS ON CALL RUN
[inaudible]
BOOSTER CLUBS.
NOW IT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL OUR
SCHOOLS NEED BOOSTER CLUB THEY
NEED THEM TO DO THE FUND RAISING
AND OR TO WE TRY TO EDUCATE OUR
DECISION MAKERS IN K. TWELVE IS
GOING.
YOUR PARENT TILL UNCLE ONE YOU
CAN'T DO THAT.
THE WE HAVE TO WORK FOR WE HAVE
TO MAKE IT FAIR FOR BOTH KIDS.
AND THEY DON'T ALWAYS WOULD YOU
EXPLAIN IT THAT WOULD A STAR TO
GO ALL.
TOTAL NINE NOT ALL THAT HARD IS
IT WHEN YOU LOOK UP HERE IT CAN
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
COLLEGIATE LEVEL THE THE
FINANCES SIDE.
I MEAN THE MONEY ON THE LEFT IS
UNCLE BOB IN THE BOOSTERS AND
ALL THE FUND RAISING THE KIDS DO
AND THEN ON THE RIGHT.
WELL THAT'S OUR DISTRICTS
BUDGETS BECAUSE IN HIGH SCHOOL
SPORTS ACROSS THE STATE IT'S
LESS THAN 2% OF THE GENERAL FUND
THEY DON'T PUT VERY MUCH MONEY
INTO IT THERE'S OTHER PRIORITIES
IN EVERYBODY GETS IT.
BUT THEY HAVE TO REMEMBER AS
LEADERS.
HERE IT DON'T TREAT OUR KIDS
DIFFERENTLY [inaudible]
GET [inaudible]
SO.
I AM EMBARRASSED BY THIS PICTURE.
THIS IS A CAMPUS IN CALIFORNIA.
LOOK AT THE BASEBALL FIELD IN
THAT PRETTY.
WELL TAKEN CARE OF THE MAN.
MAN CURED OF ME BEAUTIFUL LOOK
ON THE LEFT.
THAT'S THE SOFTBALL FIELD.
IN THE END THE RESPONSE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATORS AT THE SCHOOL
ONCE.
WELL THE BOOSTER CLUB DID THAT
THEY HIRED PEOPLE THEY DON'T ALL
THESE THINGS IN.
AND I GO BACK TO ALL HOME.
I'M NOT GONNA TREAT MY SON'S
ROOM HEY YOU GET THE BALCONY AND
YOU GET THE BIG ROOM IN YOUR
SLEEP IN THE BASEMENT CAUGHT
WOULD YOU DO THAT.
THEY GO NO.
WELL THAT'S WHAT WE JUST DID
HERE.
THE BIGGEST ISSUE I CREE CALLS
AND MY OFFICE IS THAT FACILITIES.
IN WHICH GREAT THESE DAYS IS THE
YOUNG WOMEN ARE COMMON PLAN
SPORTS THEIR DADS GET MAD.
BECAUSE THEY LOOK AT THAT GO
THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
IT IS CHANGING AND THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
WE'RE HERE.
TALKING WITH KRISTA EARLIER WE
WERE HERE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
IN THIS WAS THE SAME ISSUE AND I
MIGHT USE THAT SAME PICTURE --
THESE ARE YOUR BABIES BUT IT'S I
THE ONLY REASON I LOOK AT A LOOK
AT 200-012-1370 IT'S IT'S NOT
CHANGING THIS IS NOT BRAIN
SURGERY.
SO WHAT WE GOTTA DO.
WE NEED TO EDUCATE WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT TITLE NINE COORDINATORS IN
K. TWELVE IN THE HIGH SCHOOL
AREA -- SKEWS ME IN K. TWELVE
DISTRICTS THERE THE HUMAN
RELATIONS PERSON THEY DON'T HAVE
THE ISSUE HER THEY GOT A
THOUSAND THINGS THEY DON'T HAVE
TIME.
THERE'S WE OFFER ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT CLASSES BUT YOU GOTTA
DRAGON TO GET ON THERE BECAUSE
THEY DON'T KNOW.
WE DO ALL TYPES IN THESE THINGS
ARE IN YOUR PACKET WE DO IN
SERVICES FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BECAUSE THE BIGGEST ISSUE IS.
THEY DON'T KNOW THE QUESTIONS TO
ASK ABOUT TITLE.
NINE YOUR TITLE NINE AND THEY
GET SCARED SEXUAL HARASSMENT
LAWSUITS ALL THESE THINGS IN
THERE LIKE.
THEY DON'T KNOW THEY DON'T IF
THEY KNEW THE QUESTIONS ASKING
WOULD BE SIMPLE FOR THEM.
WE NEED TO EDUCATE.
THE DECISION MAKERS.
AFTER CAN DETER ARTICLE CHILL
TALK ABOUT IT THOUGH IS SB
THIRTY GRAY BE THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE BILL THE REPORTING WAS IT'S
GREAT DEAL.
THE NOBODY DID IT. 42% SOME SO
WE STARTED GO OKAY WE GOT
EDUCATED DECISION MAKERS I JUST
DID IT WITH THE SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE DID WITH CCESS.
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT TO EDUCATE THE
DECISION MAKERS.
YOU'RE GOING TO HATE THIS PART.
THIS ISN'T BRAIN SURGERY THIS IS
REALLY EASY AND THERE'S SO MUCH
MATERIAL SO MANY DIFFERENT
PUBLICATIONS AND THINGS THAT ARE
OUT THERE AND AVAILABLE FOR
SCHOOLS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION CHAU
OFF HER OFFICE WE COULD PUT
TOGETHER AND SIMPLE EASY THING
FOR TITLE NINE OFF COORDINATORS
TO START GETTING A UNDERSTANDING
OF THIS -- I THINK WE SAID THIS
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THIS IS ON
OUR WEBSITE ALL THESE THINGS
THAT HAPPEN TO THOSE LINKS GO
STRAIGHT TO HER OFFICE.
THERE'S SO MANY THINGS AND
THEY'RE FREE.
THEY'RE FREE UNFUNDED MANDATES
EVERYBODY'S GONNA GO CRAZY IF
YOU PUT FORWARD A BILL ANOTHER
UNFUNDED MANDATE.
IT ISN'T GONNA COST VERY MUCH
CAUSE EVERYTHING'S FREE OUT
THERE IT'S JUST A MATTER OF
SOMEBODY PUTTING IT TO GATHER.
IN SINCE I WON'T BE HERE BUT
THEY WILL I CAN VOLUNTEER CIF
WILL BE PART OF THIS IF YOU WANT.
YEAH IT'S GREAT.
SO HERE'S MY TAKEAWAYS. EIGHT
THESE ARE THE TAKE AWAYS OR
TITLING COORDINATORS THEY DON'T
KNOW THE QUESTIONS TO ASK THEY
DON'T KNOW THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN
TRAINING.
AND I YOU KNOW WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
COLLEGIATE LEVEL I DON'T THINK
THEY HAVE THE TRAINING THERE
EITHER.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T SEE IT WHEN
YOU'RE ON THE CAMPUS THE GOT A
LOOK AROUND.
ME NEW WALKING A CAMPUS YOU'D
SEE THE BY SOFTBALL BASEBALL
FIELD A ROCK.
THEY NEED TO DO THEIR OWN SELF
REVIEWS THERE IN MY BOOKS THERE
IN.
THINGS ON HER WITH IT'S REALLY
EASY TO KIND OF FIGURE OUT WHERE
MY NOT MAKING IT AND WHAT DO I
NEED TO DO TO GET BETTER.
AND THE LAST ONE YOU KNOW HOW DO
WE CLOSE AT JUST THAT GAP TO USE
ALL RIGHT THERE.
YOU CAN ASK THE KIDS WHAT WHAT
SPORTS IN THE BEGIN THAT'S PART
THERE'S A THREE PRONGED SHE MAY
HIT ON BUT PART OF IT IS ASK THE
KIDS WHAT THEY'RE WHAT ARE THEY
DON'T WANT TO PLAY WHAT ARE WE
DOING.
IT.
IT IS AMAZING WHEN YOU BUILD IT
THEY'LL COME DO IT SO IT'S
REALLY DOES FOR MY TAKEAWAYS
YEAH.
INCOME ON REMEMBER IT'S FUN FOR
KIDS IT'S FUN.
AND IT'S OUR JOB AS THE ADULTS
TO PROVIDE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEM TO HAVE FUN.
GET OFF MY SOAPBOX.
AND I BELIEVE.
OUR ANYTHING CASUALLY EXCEL BUT
ASHLEY.
SOME THE MOTO.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME MY NAME'S AUSTIN MODE
I'M GOING TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A
STATUS UPDATE ON EQUITY IN HIGH
SCHOOL ATHLETICS.
I KNOW ROGER -- HAVE TO DO A
LITTLE BIT ON NUMBERS -- IT'S
ALL KIND OF SKIP THAT BECAUSE I
ACTUALLY WENT OVER THAT AS WELL --
I MET THE PEOPLE FOR IN THIS
CLASSIC ATHLETICS WITH CAPER --
I'M ALSO KERN ATHLETIC DIRECTOR
OF AN ATHLETIC DIRECTOR FOR
EIGHT YEARS AND I'M ALSO A
PHYSICAL EDUCATOR AND THEN -- I
HAD A SON KIND OF GIVE UP
COACHING FOR THE MEANTIME BUT
WE'LL SEE IF I GET BACK INTO
THAT SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME -- SO THIS IS A THE
ONE PROGRESS AND I KNOW NUMBERS
IS AND EVERYTHING AND BUT I DID
WANT TO SHOW THAT.
WE ARE CLOSING THE GAP AND I PUT
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO BECAUSE I
WANT TO SHOW HOW FAR WE'VE COME
IN THE PAST FORTY YEARS SO --
SEVEN POINT 4% OF FEMALE SO
WHERE THE ONES WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING AND CURRENTLY IT'S
AROUND 43% -- THE SECOND
ACCOMPLISHMENT IS THAT THE GAP
IS CLOSING SO OVER TIME.
WE HAVE IN NINETEEN OUR STORY IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE
ACTUALLY HAVE OVER A MILLION
KIDS MORE PARTICIPATING NOW THAN
WE DID -- PREVIOUS YEARS -- THE
SECOND ONE AGAIN IS.
PARTICIPATION NUMBERS BY THE
STATE SO -- WE'RE RANKED ACTUAL
CALIFORNIA'S ACTUALLY RANKED
NUMBER TWO IN THE UNITED STATES
AND PARTICIPANTS -- WHICH IS
GREAT TO SEE SO WE HAVE A JUST A
LITTLE BIT OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND KIDS THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING BOTH MALE AND
FEMALES -- THE SECOND THING THAT
I WANT TO POINT OUT IS THAT WHEN
WE COMPARE TEXAS WHO WAS NUMBER
TWO NUMBER ONE AND THEY ACTUALLY
HELP ONLY HAVE LIKE.
FIVE I THINK IT'S FIVE THOUSAND
MORE KIDS PARTICIPATING SO WE'RE
WE'RE PRETTY CLOSE WITH THEM --
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY HAS MORE
FEMALES PARTICIPATING SO LOTS OF
PEOPLE ARE AS WE DO -- YOU KNOW
AND IT EQUATES TO ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND MORE FEMALES ARE
PARTICIPATING SO -- IT WAS GREAT
TO SEE THAT WHEN I WAS LOOKING
THROUGH THE DATA.
AND THE NEXT THING.
THAT I WANT TO GO OVER IS I PUT
IN A CALL IN THE QUALITY AND
ATHLETIC SO -- AGAIN I'M NOT A
SINGLE SITE I SEE THE SMALLER
SCHOOL DIVISIONS BECAUSE I'M AT
A SMALLER SCHOOL WE PLAY LIKE
THE FORTY FIVE D. SIX AND I
ACTUALLY EMAILED OUT TO ALL OF
THE CENTRAL SECTION BECAUSE I'M
FROM FRESNO.
AND I GIVE A SURVEY.
AND I KIND OF WANTED TO SEE
WHERE EVERYBODY WAS WHERE THEY
SAW THAT THEY FELT THAT THEY
WERE.
ON BOARD WITH WHAT THEY FELT
THEY AGREED WITH VERSES -- WHERE
THEY DID IT SO AS YOU CAN SEE --
PETE'S TYPE IN AMOUNTS OF THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT -- THEY AGREED TO
WITH THE PRACTICE FACILITIES
THEY AGREED WERE -- PRETTY
EQUITABLE ALLOCATION OF TRAVEL
AND TRANSPORTATION SO BOYS AND
GIRLS THE TEAMS ARE PRETTY EVEN.
FACILITIES GAME AND PRACTICE
TIMES ACADEMIC TUTORING AND
UNLOCK ROOM FACILITY FACILITIES
SO THE MIXER RESPONSES -- WHICH
IS A GREAT TO SEE BECAUSE IT'S
ABOUT HALF OF THE ITEMS THAT I
THAT I PUT OUT THERE WAS A
PUBLICITY SO THIS ALL THAT --
ONE SIX IS BEING MORE PUBLICIZED
IN THE OTHER FACILITIES AND OF
FOR NOT WHAT ACTUALLY TRAINER
MEDICAL SERVICES SO MY THOUGHTS
ON THIS WERE MORE HAVING TO GO
WITH FOOTBALL AND SO LIKE AT
WITH THE FOOTBALL SPORT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE AN AMBULANCE
THERE.
A TRAINER THAT TYPE OF THING SO
THAT'S MY THOUGHT I'M GOING IN
THAT DIRECTION MAYBE THAT'S
WHERE THE UNFAIRNESS WAS -- THE
FOURTH ONE WAS EQUITY IN FUNDS
PROVIDED BY THE DISTRICT TO PAY
FOR EQUIPMENT.
SO WITH IN MY DISTRICT WE
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE BOOSTERS SO
THE SO OUR DISTRICT ACTUALLY
PROVIDES A LOT OF MONEY -- FOR
OUR FOR OUR ATHLETIC PROGRAMS
AND SO -- MY THOUGHTS AGAIN WITH
THIS ONE ARE.
FOOTBALL HELMETS PADS. FOR A
HUNDRED HUNDRED TWENTY KIDS IS
PRETTY EXPENSIVE -- THE CLEMENT
BUT THE UTILIZES EXPENSIVE SO
I'M JUST THINKING IN IN THAT
ASPECT THAT MAYBE.
THAT'S WHERE THE INEQUITY OF
FUNDS IS FROM AND THE COACHING
POSITION SO -- YOU LOOK AT A
FOOTBALL STAFF WHICH USUALLY HAS.
I DON'T KNOW TEN MAYBE YOU KNOW
DEPENDING ON HOW MANY LEVELS
THEY HAVE AND YOU CAN'T REALLY
COMPARE OF FOOTBALL STAFF TO OF
ALL ABLE STAFF. FOR SOFTBALL
STAFF SO GOING THROUGH THAT --
SO ATTENTION AREAS I'M GONNA GO
BACK TO THE NUMBERS -- SO
FOOTBALL'S NUMBER ONE SO IN THE
NATION WE HAVE.
MILLION KIDS OVER MILLION KIDS
EVERY YEAR PLAYING FOOTBALL AND
THERE'S REALLY.
NO OTHER SPORT THAT CAN COMPARE
LOOKING AT THE FEMALE ASPECTS OF
TEXAS HAS A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR THOUSANDS OF PARTICIPATING
CALIFORNIA HAS NINETY FOUR AND
THEN THE THIRD. ONE IS ACTUALLY
BUT FORTY TWO THOUSAND SO -- WE
ARE IN THEM UP THERE WITH THE
MOUNTIE KIDS PARTICIPATING SO
THEN WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO LOOK
AT NUMBERS.
YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T COMPARE.
THE MALES TO FEMALES -- BUT THEN
IF LOOKING OVER AT THE MALES
THEY ACTUALLY.
THE TRACK AND FIELD AND FOOTBALL
IS.
THE MOST POPULAR SPORTS FOR
MALES AND FEMALES -- BUT YOU CAN
SEE THEY STILL HAVE AN
OUTRAGEOUS AMOUNT A NUMBER MORE
MALES PARTICIPATING THAN FEMALES
AND THEN WHEN YOU LOOK DOWN AT
TENNIS WE ACTUALLY HAVE TENNIS
HAS MORE FEMALE SO THAT'S GREAT
TO SEE THAT THE MALLS THERE IS A
FEW MOST WORN OUT THERE THAT HAS
MORE.
PARTICIPANTS THAN MALES -- BUT
YOU COULD SEE THERE'S JUST AN
OUTRAGEOUS AMOUNT OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE -- THE PARTICIPATING
WHICH IS GREAT BECAUSE ASYOU
CAN SEE OUR NUMBERS ARE HIGH BUT
THERE'S STILL MORE -- MALES.
PARTICIPATING THEN -- FEMALES SO
BIG THING IS LET'S TALK MONEY IS
SO AGAIN WITH THE WHEN THIS IS
WHAT THE SURVEY I SENT OUT -- IT
WAS -- OVERWHELMINGLY I THINK
THERE'S ONE PROGRAM THAT SAID
THAT BASKETBALL WAS THEIR NUMBER
ONE PRODUCING REVENUE.
FOOTBALL WAS NUMBER ONE FOR
EVERYBODY SO THAT'S WHERE THE
MONEY MAKER IS AND MY DISTRICT
THEN OUT AND A LOT OF OTHER
DISTRICTS.
FOOTBALL REVENUE PAYS FOR
TOURNAMENTS OFFICIALS THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S WHERE YOUR BANK IS
SO -- MY ASSUMPTION IS MORE TIME
MONEY AND EFFORT IS TYPICALLY
SPENT ON FOOTBALL -- IT'S NOT A
GREAT THING TO SEE BUT AS AN
ATHLETIC DIRECTOR I KNOW WHEN
FROM FRIDAY NIGHT COMES THERE'S
A LOT THAT GOES INTO IT YOU HAVE
TO ALIGN YOUR OFFICIALS --
SECURITY -- CROWD CONTROL ARE
YOU HAVING OF EVENT THAT NIGHT
TO PER.
YOUR ELEMENTARY SCHOOL --
THERE'S JUST A LOT OF THAT GOES
INTO FOOTBALL WHICH IS YOUR
NUMBER ONE PRODUCING A LOT OF
TIMES FOOTBALLS.
YOUR SCHOOL LIKE THAT'S WHAT
REPRESENTED REPRESENTS YOUR
SCHOOL IS YOUR FOOTBALL TEAM --
IT'S NOT GREAT TO SEE -- BUT
WHEN THE FALL COMES THAT'S
TYPICALLY WHAT HAPPENS -- AND
BOYS BASKETBALL -- YOU CAN EARN
A BASS BASKETBALL OR SOCCER
THERE YOU CAN COMPARE THE TWO SO
THAT'S KINDA WHAT I MEAN ABOUT
EQUALITY IS YOU CAN COMPARE BUT
THERE'S REALLY NO.
THE MOST MORE THAT COMPARES TO
FOOTBALL AND THEN -- I DID WANT
TO KNOW WHAT THE SAUDIS FOR
PLAYOFFS IN THE CENTRAL SECTION
WE ARE ACTUALLY MOVING AND I
KNOW BASEBALL IS AT A MINOR
LEAGUE FACILITY FOR BASEBALL AND
THEN THAT WOULD HAPPEN FOR A
YEAR AND THEN WE ACTUALLY MOVED.
US OFF ALL TO THE PRESENT STATE
MARTY RIGHT STADIUM SO THAT
THAT'S COMPARATIVO I'M NOT SURE
ABOUT.
THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE STATE
WE ALSO HAVE A BASKETBALL
PLAYOFFS AT HOME SO AN ARENA IN
FRESNO AND THEN I KNOW THE STATE
WE HAVE IT AT WAS KEPT COUPLE.
ONE GOLDEN GOLDEN ONE THERE YOU
GOT MORE THAN ONE CENTER SO IT
WAS IT'S GREAT TO SEE THAT OUR
OUR KIDS ARE ABLE TO GO INTO
THOSE SITUATIONS AND PLAY AND
FACILITIES THAT.
ARE -- NOT JUST SPECIFIC TO
THEIR SCHOOL -- BUT I KNOW THE
CENTRAL SECTION HAS SAID WOULD
THEY MAKE MORE MONEY WHEN IT'S
AT THESE FACILITIES BECAUSE YOU
HAVE ALL THE SPORTS IN ONE AREA
SO AGAIN SOMETIMES THAT'S MONEY
DRIVEN -- I ALSO IN THE SURVEY I
ASKED HOW MANY SCHOOLS WERE IN
MARIN MEASURES AND THERE'S ABOUT
55% OF SCHOOLS THAT HAD BOND
MEASURES.
THAT WERE BEING USED TOWARDS
ATHLETICS SO -- WHEN YOU LOOK AT
BUDGETS -- LIKE YOU SAID WAS A
2% OF IT IS IS WITH ATHLETIC SO
THEY'RE LOOKING TO THE
COMMUNITIES TO TO FIND THESE
NEWS NEW FACILITIES.
I NOT MY SCHOOL -- WE HAVE THE
OUR FACILITIES ARE VERY OLD AND
SO I KNOW IN THE FUTURE THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO LOOK TO
BECAUSE THEY'RE EXPENSIVE AND WE
DO WANT.
TO YOU KNOW HAVE NO A A SUPPLE
STADIUM BECAUSE WE HAVE A
BASEBALL -- ONE WE ARE STUDENTS
BACKYARD OUR KIDS PLAY BECAUSE
IT'S FUN -- AND WE NEED TO
PROVIDE EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES
EQUAL -- FACILITIES FOR A KID SO
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
AGAIN OUR PARTICIPATION RATES
ARE UP -- UPGRADES ARE HAPPENING
BUT AGAIN IT'S NOT AT THE RATE
THAT WE NEED TO SEE IT SO WE
NEED -- TO INCREASE THAT AND
THEN.
THE COMPLAINTS OFFICER IS GREAT
TO SEE I'VE SEEN AS AN ATHLETIC
DIRECTOR MY ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT IS COMING TO ME
MAKING SURE THAT I HAVE ALL OF
MY SERVICE FILLED OUT AND WE GO
THROUGH THINGS AND IT'S GREAT.
AS AN ATHLETIC DIRECTOR BECAUSE
IT'S I HAVE SOMEBODY THERE
REMINDING ME SO THAT'S A
POSITIVE.
COMING FROM MY POSITION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR AND NOW.
RE INTRODUCED -- CAM TURNER.
AND THE THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY.
HI MY NAME IS KIM TURNER AND I'M
A SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY FOR FAIR
PLAY FOR GIRLS IN SPORTS A
PROJECT OF OUR ONE HUNDRED YEAR
OLD NONPROFIT.
ORGANIZATION LEGAL AID AT WORK
BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I'M ALSO PLEASED TO BE HERE
BECAUSE ON A PERSONAL NOTE I
TITLE NINE A DEBT OF GRATITUDE I
PLAYED DIVISION ONE VOLLEYBALL
IN COLLEGE AT BROWN UNIVERSITY.
AND WOULD NOT HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY BUT FOR THE
LAW THEY WERE ABOUT TO ELIMINATE
THE VOLLEYBALL WOMEN'S PROGRAM
AND SEVERAL OTHER WOMEN SPORTS
PROGRAMS IN THE NINETIES AND THE
PROGRAM I PLAYED FOR AND THE
OTHER WOMEN SPORTS PERCEIVED BY.
A GROUP OF COURAGEOUS WOMEN WHO
SAID NO WE ARE JUST AS IMPORTANT
AS FOOTBALL AND EVERY OTHER
SPORT IN THIS UNIVERSITY AND WE
CANNOT USE FEDERAL FUNDS TO
DISCRIMINATE SO THANK YOU TITLE
NINE PERSONALLY -- SO THROUGH
LITIGATION EDUCATION AND POLICY
WORK WE ADVOCATE AT FAIR PLAY
FOR GENDER EQUALITY WITH A
SPECIFIC FOCUS ON AN EQUITY IN
ATHLETICS FOR THE THREE MILLION
GIRLS IN GRADES K. THROUGH
TWELVE ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE SEEK TO BRING ABOUT EQUITY
FOR GIRLS USING TITLE NINE AND
RELATED CALIFORNIA LAW.
PARTICULARLY THOSE -- FOR THOSE
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
GIRLS OF COLOR WHO STATISTICALLY
HAVE THE FEWEST SPORTS
OPPORTUNITIES IN COMPARISON TO
THE U. SPEARS.
AND WE WORKED IN THE STATE FOR
OVER FIFTEEN YEARS ON TITLE NINE
MATTERS REPRESENTING GIRLS AND
THEIR FAMILIES OR SCHOOLS ARE
REATING GIRLS AS A SECOND CLASS
THESE GIRLS ARE STANDING UP TO
MAKE CHANGE WITH OUR ASSISTANCE.
AND FAIR PLAY FURTHER PROVIDES
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL HELP.
AND LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY TO MOVE
TOWARD THE GOAL OF GENDER EQUITY
FOR OUR STUDENTS ONCE AND FOR
ALL AND I JUST WANT TO ADVERTISE
THAT ANYONE IN THIS ROOM WHO
WANTS A TITLE NINE TRAINING.
WE'RE READY TO DO IT BECAUSE I
THINK AS ALL TALK ABOUT A LITTLE
BIT MORE THERE'S SOME
MISUNDERSTANDING ABOUT HOW THE
LAW WORKS AND WE NEED TO CHANGE
THAT.
SO DESPITE GREAT STRIDES WITH
TITLE NINE APPROACHING ITS
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY
UNFORTUNATELY MILLIONS OF GIRLS
NATIONWIDE AND IN CALIFORNIA ARE
BEING SIMPLY TREATED WORSE THAN
THE BOYS.
SO LIKE A ONE LIKE A YOUNG WOMAN
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHO
SOUGHT THE HELP OF FAIR PLAY
BECAUSE IN HER WORDS AND HER
PUBLIC SCHOOL.
IT WAS LACKING RESOURCES FOR
GIRLS WHILE PUTTING BOYS ON A
PEDESTAL AND GIVING THEM THE
BEST FACILITIES.
ACTORS ASSERTING A TITLE NINE
COMPLAINT AGAINST HER SCHOOL
CHANGES WERE MADE TO IMPROVE AN
EQUALIZED GIRLS ATHLETICS THERE
AND SHE SAID TITLE NINE GIVE
GIRLS THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHINE.
JUST AS MUCH AS THE BOYS.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY AND
I THINK WE HAVE TO KEEP
REMEMBERING THAT.
SO WHAT EXACTLY IS THIS PROBLEM
OF ATHLETIC INEQUITY WHY DOES IT
MATTER AND WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO
ABOUT IT AFTER TODAY.
EVERY DAY IN CALIFORNIA OUR
ELEMENTARY MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOLS ARE TELLING GIRLS YOU
CAN DO ANYTHING IF YOU STUDY
HARD FOR ALL THE RULES AND
GRADUATE.
THE GIRLS ARE ALSO GETTING A
CORROSIVE MESSAGE FROM SCHOOLS
THAT THEY DON'T COUNT AS MUCH AS
THEIR MALE PEERS ON OUR KEY TOLD
CAMPUSES.
IN THE WORDS OF ANOTHER FAIR
PLAY KLEIN IN HIGH SCHOOL I FEEL
LIKE I'M LEFT OUT AND CONSTANTLY
HAVING TO FIGHT FOR MY EQUITY
AND WORK FIVE TIMES HARDER FOR
THE OPPORTUNITIES AND SUCCESSES
THAT I WANT AS AN ATHLETE.
IT FEELS LIKE WE GIRLS DON'T
MATTER AS MUCH.
SO FOR EXAMPLE ACROSS THE STATE
SCHOOLS ARE AFFORDING BOYS
LARGER MORE UP TO DATE ATHLETIC
LOCKER ROOMS AND ACCESS TO THE
PREFERRED JAMS AND FIELDS AND IN
CONTRAST GIRLS HAVE SMALLER
LOCKER ROOMS WITH LESS AMENITIES
OR NO LOCKER ROOM AT ALL.
AND THEY HAVE THE WORST ATHLETIC
FACILITIES FOR PRACTICE AND PLAY.
NO I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR AND
WANT TO DO A QUICK POINT OF
EDUCATION HERE TO MY CO
PANELISTS WHO VERY CAREFULLY AND
AND HOPEFULLY TALK ABOUT WHAT
WHAT THEY'RE SEEING.
TREATMENT IN BENEFITS IS ONE
AREA OF TITLE NINE SO WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THE WHOLE ATHLETIC
PROGRAM AND LOOK AT WHAT ALL THE
BOYS AND ALL THE GIRLS ARE
GETTING ON THEIR DIFFERENT TEAMS.
VERY CLEARLY TITLE NINE IN THE
REGULATION SAY THERE'S NO
EXCEPTION FOR FOOTBALL IT
DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED BOYS PLAYING FOOTBALL.
YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S EQUITABLE TREATMENT
BENEFITS FOR THE GIRLS ON THE
GIRLS SIDE.
IT'S OKAY TO HAVE A MORE
EXPENSIVE FOOTBALL UNIFORMS BUT
THE SOFTBALL GIRLS NEED TO HAVE
A TOP NOTCH UNIFORM AS WELL AND
ALL THE ELEMENTS FOR THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED SAME WITH THE
SWIMMERS.
SAME WITH FIELD HOCKEY WHATEVER
IT MAY BE FOOTBALL GREAT SPORT
NOT AGAINST IT WE JUST WANNA
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THERE IS NO
FOOTBALL EXCEPTION IN TITLE NINE
AND WE HEAR THAT TOO OFTEN FROM
SCHOOLS.
THAT THERE'S NO WAY AROUND IT.
AS THE OPPORTUNITIES TO PLAY A
GIRLS MAKE UP HALF OF OUR
CALIFORNIA STUDENT BODY AND
RESEARCH CLEARLY SHOWS THEY WANT
TO PLAY SPORTS AS MUCH AS THE
BOYS ESPECIALLY IF THE SPORTS
ARE OFFERED IN THE RIGHT WAY.
SO THAT MEANS IF YOU HEAR AN
ATHLETIC DIRECTOR SAY NO GIRLS
AT THE SCHOOL WANTED TO PLAY
SOFTBALL AND THEN YOU FIND OUT
THAT THE SOFTBALL FIELD IS UNDER
THE FREEWAY.
AND THE BOYS BASEBALL FIELD THE
CENTRAL CAMPUS THERE'S A REASON
THEY'RE NOT PLANNING SO I CAN'T
WAIT FOR THOSE UPGRADED
FACILITIES TO COME BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
PARTICIPATION.
AND THEN IF GIRLS HAVE EQUAL
FACILITIES KNOWLEDGEABLE COACHES
IN THE SCHOOL SUPPORT THEY WILL
COME.
BUT OUR EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
ARE OFFERING FEWER SUPPORT
PROGRAMS AND FEWER LEVELS OF
SPORTS IN COMPARISON TO GIRLS.
AND IN COMPARISON TO BOYS AND SO
IF YOU HAVE A HUNDRED BOYS ON
THE FOOTBALL PROGRAM.
YOU PROBABLY HAVE A LOT OF GIRLS
THAT WANT TO PLAY VOLLEYBALL BUT
YOU ONLY HAVE ONE TEAM OR TWO
YOU COULD HAVE FIVE LEVELS OF
VOLLEYBALL THESE DAYS YOU COULD
HAVE THREE LEVELS OF STOP ALL
THESE DAYS THE GIRLS WANT TO
PLAY.
BUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE FROM THE
SCHOOL HAS TO BE BUILT.
SO AS MY COLLEAGUE RODGER BLAKE
DISCUSSED WOULD WE EVER GIVE
FEMALE STUDENTS FEWER DUSTIN
BOYS IN THE CLASSROOM OR GIVE
GIRLS OLDER BOOKS IN COMPARISON
TO BOYS OR SIGN GIRLS TEACHERS
WHO DIDN'T KNOW MATH AS WELL AS
TEACHERS WORKING WITH BOYS.
WHY ARE WE DONE GIVING GIRLS
FEWER ATHLETIC ROSTER SPOTS IN
COMPARISON TO BOYS WHO HAVE AT
LEASTA HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE
SLOTS ON TEAMS IN CALIFORNIA?
WHY ARE WE GIVING GIRLS OLDER
INFERIOR ATHLETIC UNIFORMS THAT
THEIR SEWING THEMSELVES THE
SOFTBALL PANTS WITH HOLES WHILE
THE BOYS ARE GETTING SIX SETS OF
UNIFORMS IN THEIR BASEBALL
PROGRAM? ONE OF THE MAIN CAMERA
COLORS.
AND WHY ARE WE GIVING BOYS MORE
EQUIPMENT AND NICER EQUIPMENT IN
COMPARISON TO GIRLS TEAMS.
AND THEN FINALLY WIRE WE
ASSIGNING GIRLS TEAMS COACHES
WHO SOMETIMES HAVE NEVER EVEN
PLAYED THE SPORT ON THE GIRLS
TEAM WHERE IS BOYS COACHES ALL
TOO OFTEN WERE ONCE
PROFESSIONALS IN THEIR GAME.
AND TO ANYONE WHO SAYS WELL IT'S
THE BOOSTER CLUBS TIPPING THE
SCALES WOULD WE EVER ALLOW
SOMEONE LIKE BILL GATES TO
DONATE COMPUTERS JUST TO THE
BOYS BUT NOT TO THE GIRLS.
NO SO WE NEED TO STOP THE
PRACTICE OF ALLOWING SCHOOLS AND
WIDER COMMUNITIES TO SUPPORT
BOYS SPORTS OVER GIRLS SPORTS
PERIOD.
NO EXCEPTIONS.
ATHLETICS IN SCHOOL IS ABOUT
LEARNING AND GROWING AND EVERY
STUDENT DESERVES THE SAME CHANCE
TO PLAN FLOURISH REGARDLESS OF
GENDER.
FURTHER A SCHOOL'S ATHLETIC
PROGRAM IS A MICROCOSM OF
SOCIETY WHERE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TEACH GIRLS AND
BOYS ABOUT GENDER EQUITY.
WE MUST EXEMPLIFY EQUITY AND
FOSTER FAIRNESS THROUGHOUT
EDUCATION SO THAT THESE STUDENTS
WILL GO INTO THE WORLD AND THE
WORKPLACE HAVING LEARNED AND
ABSORB THAT EQUITY IS THE LAW
AND IT'S WHAT'S RIGHT FROM THE
START.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES EQUITY MATTER
IN ATHLETICS WHY ARE WELL FOR
ONE GIRLS WHO PLAY SPORTS ARE
HEALTHIER PHYSICALLY MENTALLY
AND THEY GRADUATED HIGHER RATES?
BUT FEMALE ATHLETES WHO PLAYED
IN HIGH SCHOOL GO ON TO EARN 7%
HIGHER WE JUST AS ADULTS
REGARDLESS OF ANY OTHER THING OR
VARIABLE IN THEIR BACKGROUND.
SO THIS IS ABOUT MORE THAN FUNNY
GAMES IT'S A DOLLARS AND CENTS
ESPECIALLY FOR GIRLS SEEKING
ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
USING THE LESSONS AND
EXPERIENCES THAT THEY LEARNED IN
SPORTS TO BETTER THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT LARGER
PAYCHECK.
NOW WE KNOW THAT THERE IS AN
EPIDEMIC PROBLEM OF INEQUITY IN
OUR SCHOOLS THINGS ARE GETTING
BETTER AS MY COLLEAGUES POINTED
OUT BUT WE ARE NOT AT THE FINISH
LINE YET.
THERE ARE THREE THINGS THAT FAIR
PLAY RECOMMENDS THAT WE DO TO
TAKE ACTION.
FROM IN TERMS OF THE CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION THE
OFFICE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS THE
CALIFORNIA AG'S OFFICE EVERYBODY
HERE TODAY CAN HELP.
THE LAWMAKERS HERE AND IN
WASHINGTON AND ALL OF OUR ALLIES
AROUND THE ROOM.
NUMBER ONE TRAINING WE MUST ALSO
DECIDE TIME AND RESOURCES TO
PROPERLY TRAIN THE
SUPERINTENDENTS PRINCIPALS
COACHES TEACHERS STUDENTS
FAMILIES ON WHAT TITLE IN
ATHLETICS ACTUALLY EQUITY IN
ATHLETICS ACTUALLY MEANS AND
LOOKS LIKE IN OUR SCHOOLS.
AND I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT A
TRAINING WHERE IT'S A WEAPON ARE
YOU SIT BACK AND YOU GET ON YOUR
PHONE YOU DON'T PAY ATTENTION
BECAUSE WE SADLY SEE THAT TOO
OFTEN WITHOUT.
A POLITIC DIRECTORS IN
LITIGATION SAY I WAS TRAINED ON
TITLE NINE AND I DON'T REMEMBER
WORD OF IT.
OKAY WE NEED TO INSTILL THAT
THIS IS ACTUALLY IMPORTANT AND
THESE TRAINING RESOURCES TO
ROGER'S POINT ALREADY EXIST BUT
THEY NEED TO BE FURTHER
DEVELOPED AND THEY NEED TO BE
EFFECTIVELY APPLIED.
AND TRAINING CAN ONLY WORK IN
INSTITUTIONS THAT ESTABLISH THAT
EQUITY IS THE NON NEGOTIABLE
ORDER OF THE DAY.
SO NOT ONLY DOES THE ATHLETIC
DIRECTOR NEED TO PROPERLY
UNDERSTAND TITLE NINE COMPLIANCE
AFFORDING GIRLS ENOUGH TEAMS
ROTATING LOCKER ROOMS WHEN ONE
IS INFERIOR.
AND PRACTICE TIMES AND AND GAME
TIMES FOR EQUITY.
THEY NEED TO MAKE IT HAPPEN DAY
IN AND DAY OUT SUPPORTING IN
THEIR SPIRIT AND IN THE
RESOURCES THAT IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT BOYS FOOTBALL IN THAT BIG
GAME AND THE PEP RALLY ONLY FOR
BOYS.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A PEP RALLY FOR
GIRLS SOFTBALL WE'VE HAD
SITUATIONS WHERE CA YEP.
YOU KNOW GIRLS TEAMS HAVE WON C.
I. F. STATE CHAMPIONSHIPS AND NO
ONE AT THE SCHOOL KNOWS ABOUT IT
SO WE NEED TO CHANGE THAT.
SECOND WE NEED TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING MANDATE
SO AS ROGER MENTIONED EARLIER SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE REQUIRES K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS TO REPORT ON HOW
MANY GIRLS AND BOYS ARE PLAYING.
HALF OF THE SCHOOLS ARE
REPORTING WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A 100% BECAUSE JUST LIKE
WE WANT TO KNOW HOW THE SCHOOLS
PERFORMING ACADEMICALLY FOR OUR
STUDENTS WE WANT TO KNOW IF
WE'RE GONNA CENTER SON AND
DAUGHTER TO THAT SCHOOL.
pTHEY'RE GOING TO GET THE SAME
ATHLETIC RESOURCES.
AND THEN WE ALSO NEED THIRD. TO
PUT THE BURDEN ON OURSELVES AND
OUR INSTITUTIONS AND AGENCIES
NONPROFITS AND LEADERS TO MAKE
THESE CHANGES AND NOT THE BURDEN
ON THE GIRLS.
BECAUSE TOO OFTEN WE'RE SAYING
TO THESE GIRLS YOU NEED TO MAKE
THE COMPLAINT YOU NEED TO STICK
YOUR NECK OUT IN MIDDLE SCHOOL
IN HIGH SCHOOL I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU REMEMBER HIGH SCHOOL BUT
USUALLY YOU DON'T WANT TO BE IN
FEDERAL COURT IF YOU CAN AVOID
IT.
BECAUSE YOU'RE DEALING WITH A
LOT OF OTHER THINGS.
SO SHOULDN'T THESE GIRLS BE
SPENDING THEIR TIME STUDYING
LEARNING PREPARING FOR COLLEGE
AND NOT PREPARING A COMPLAINT.
TO CALL DEPARTMENT OF ED OR OCR.
FOR TO A FEDERAL COURT SO LET'S
NOT PUT THE GROUP BURDEN ON
GIRLS AND INSTEAD LET'S USE OUR
RESOURCES TODAY AMONGST
OURSELVES TO EXPAND AND UTILIZE
TITLE NINE GUIDANCE TO ASSESS
FOR INEQUITY.
QUICKLY BRING THE PROBLEMS TO
LIGHT NOT IN FIFTY MORE YEARS
TODAY THIS WEEK THIS MONTH THIS
YEAR AND CREATE A TRULY LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD ONCE AND FOR ALL
BECAUSE TIME'S UP ON
DISCRIMINATION IN EDUCATION.
THANK YOU.
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
LEARN MUCH OF A WILL ALSO A
VOLLEYBALL DEMONSTRATION LATER
FOR YOUR PASSION AND ON BEHALF
OF MY SIX YEAR OLD GRANDDAUGHTER
I ALSO WANNA.
THANK ALL OF YOU HERE AND THE
PANELISTS TO FOR YOU FOR YOUR
WORK AND AND AND THIS -- EQUITY
ISSUE -- SURE BLOOM DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE PANELISTS.
QUESTIONS BUT I WILL I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE PARTICIPANTS TODAY --
FOR ENLIGHTENING US ON ON THESE
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES AND OF
CLEARLY ARE ALL PASSIONATE ABOUT --
ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND YOU
SHOULD BE AND WE ALL SHOULD BE
BECAUSE THE QUALITY IS THE WATCH
WORD OF THE DAY AND WE'RE NOT
THERE YET AND AND WE NEED TO
WORK HARD TO GET THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHALL
CONSIDER US AS YOUR PARTNER.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR A CUTTING.
YOU KNOW I THIS IS MY FIFTH YEAR
IN THE ASSEMBLY I WAS TRYING --
TO PROMOS A STEAM EDUCATION WITH
A CAPITAL A SAMPLE ARTS.
UNDER THE IN THE SAME --
EDUCATION BUT IT'S IT.
CENTER I'M NOT GOING ANYWHERE SO
WE MAYBE YOU'LL COULD HELP US.
MAYBE POST SO MORE ARTS AND IN
IN THE THE SCHOOL.
SIR WITH LOVE -- TO PARTNER WITH
YOU WORK WITH YOU ON THAT --
CERTAINLY THE SUPERINTENDENT
HAVING BEEN THE THE ASSEMBLY --
CHAIR OF THE STEM CAUCUS AND WE
DON'T WANT TO FORGET THE A STEM
STEAM CAUCUS AND CERTAINLY AS A
AS A GRADUATE -- IN -- THE STEM
PROFESSION -- WE LOVE TO PARTNER
WITH YOU SIR.
WHEN?
YOU ADD THE ARTS TO THE
PARTICIPATION OF STUDENTS IN
HIGH SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
73% OF OUR KIDS ARE INVOLVED IN
ATHLETICS THE ARTS IN OUR
CAMPUSES.
IT'S A VOLUNTARY THINK THEY
DON'T HAVE TO PLACE WHERE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE IN DRAMA AND
CHOIR.
YOUR SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS THAT
ARE COMING UP TODAY GOING TO
CLASSES I DON'T THINK THEY
RECOGNIZE ALL TOO OFTEN.
THOSE VALUES THAT ARE ALL ACROSS
OUR CAMPUS UNLESS THEY'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THAT.
ON IT'S TOO BAD TODAY THAT THE
EDUCATORS THEY ARE SO
OVERWHELMED WITH HAVING TO TEST
SCORES AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT.
BUT THEY'RE FORGETTING ABOUT A
REALLY UNDER FUNDED UNDER VALUED
THING ON THEIR CAMPUS THAT MAKES
A HUGE DIFFERENCE FOR THEIR
CULTURE.
SHE SAID IT KIDS ARE INVOLVED IN
IT LET'S JUST GET OUT OF
ATHLETICS AND ACTIVITIES OVERALL
THEY DO BETTER.
THE EXCEL IT SO.
THAT'S GOT TO BE AN EMPHASIS
WITH OUR EDUCATIONAL LEADERS
THEY'VE GOT TO GET BACK TO
RECOGNIZING HOW IMPORTANT IT IS.
THESE ARE SONS AND DAUGHTERS
THEY JUST WANNA HAVE FUN AND A
CHANCE. TO GO DO IT.
AND THEY'VE AND OUR EDUCATIONAL
LEADERS FORGET.
THANK YOU NOW WE'LL HAVE SOME
FUN AND TO KNOW OR OPEN UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT I WON THE OF I
THINK TWO YEARS WILL ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
AND WOULD REALLY LIKE TO HEAR
FROM YOU SO ANY -- A PUBLIC DOWN
MAHLER TO MAKE A COMMENT OR ASK.
PLEASE COME.
FOR AND WE WOULD USE A
MICROPHONE FROM WHERE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OF HELLO TEARS AND RESPECTED
MEMBERS OF THIS JOINT COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MARK J. GREEN I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL AFFAIRS
FOR THE ASSOCIATED STUDENTS OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY OR A AS YOU SEE --
THOUGH GO BEARS -- THOUGH I MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE MANY STUDENTS WHO HAD TO
DEPART FROM THIS HEARING BEFORE
PUBLIC COMMENT I AM PROUD TO
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THEM --
SO TITLE NINE IS UNDER SERIOUS
THREAT ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES
TO CAMPUS SEXUAL MISCONDUCT I
ALONG WITH STUDENT LEADERS
SURVIVORS AND PASSIONATE
ACTIVISTS HAVE MET FOUR TIMES
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S OFFICE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS -- AND FACILITATED
MEETINGS WITH -- HUNDRED
COMPRESSION -- NEARLY MORE THAN
A HUNDRED MEETINGS WITH
CONGRESSIONAL OFFICES OVER THE
PAST TWO YEARS WITH TITLE NINE
IS A CONSISTENT PLATFORM.
THE DEPARTMENT'S RULES WHICH
SEEK TO ADVANCE THE FLOOD
NARRATIVE OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
POSE A GRAVE DANGER TO STUDENTS
ON OUR CAMPUSES -- I WANT TO
AFTER THE CONCERNS PRESENTED
OVER THE COURSE OF THIS HEARING
OUR STUDENTS HAVE EXPRESSED IN
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
WHIMS WITH THE OFF CAMPUS ROLE
DEFINING SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS
SEVERE PERVASIVE AND OBJECTIVELY
OFFENSIVE.
THE PROPOSED CHANGES IN THE
EVIDENTIARY STANDARDS THE
PROPOSED THE POTENTIAL RULE
MANDATING CROSS EXAMINATIONS OF
COMPLAINTS BY THE RESPONDENT'S
COUNSEL DANGEROUS AND OF COURSE
THE DANGERS TREATMENT.
OF TRANSGENDER AND LGBT Q. FOLKS --
BY THIS ADMINISTRATION --
CALIFORNIA HAS AS OUR WANT LED
THE NATION IN IMPLEMENTING
POLICIES THAT TO INSURE TITLE
NINE LIVES UP TO AND EXCEEDS ITS
ORIGINAL AMBITIONS NO MATTER THE
MAKE UP OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND SO I WANT TO EXHORT THIS
COMMITTEE THIS LEGISLATURE AND
THE STATE TO BE ACTIVE ALLIES IN
PROTECTING STUDENTS -- WHETHER
IT IS IN THE FORM OF SENATOR
JACKSON'S SP FOUR NINE THREE OR
BEYOND -- THOSE RULES MAY BE
STUCK AS THE DEPARTMENT
PROCESSES COMMENTS BUT THERE
SHOULD BE NO HESITATION IN DOING
ALL THAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO TO
GIVE OUR STUDENTS SECURITY AND
MAKE OUR CAMPUSES SAFE AND I
WANT TO THANK.
THE COMMITTEE FOR CONVENE AROUND
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC.
WELL THE SCENE -- I AGAIN WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU.
FOR THIS FIRST SPECIALLY THE
PUBLIC FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
SPRING.
A GOOD TWO HOURS ARE HEARING AND
I THINK WE ALL AGREED ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROMOTING GREATER
UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE EXISTING LEGAL STRUCTURES
FAN AND THAT IDENTIFYING THE
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS TO ENSURE
THE GOAL OF EDUCATION.
THE REGARDLESS OF THE GENDERS
ARE MET SO AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SAYING TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE.
FOR AND ALL OF YOU FOR JOINING
IN AND TO SO -- A HEARING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH